[Music]
hello and welcome to another episode of
trash taste i am your host for today
gant and with me as usual are the boys
joey and uh whoever whoever this baby
man is right now and uh 15 year old
connor we got 15 year old connor and uh
once again we have another special guest
with us
uh if you remember it's been has it been
exactly one year
a little close very close to that yeah
pretty close i think it's been a little
bit over a year but uh i'm glad to see
you guys again always happy to to um
appear as a guest if you will have me
who are you introduce yourself i guess i
should do that people that don't know
hi my name is murray calliope and i am
from whole live english first generation
myth and um basically i'm the first
apprentice of the grim reaper but i
mostly do like music and streaming these
days uh so yeah thank you very much for
having me i have been on the podcast
before actually this is round number two
highly requested didn't get enough yeah
yeah
yeah we would shut the convenience oh
yeah oh kelly
quality top quality
nice yeah so how have you been it's been
like it's been like a good year oh man
um you know tired but good
tired but good i think could you be more
tired than last time remember last time
you were like you're like grim reaper
has a part-time job and a part-time job
yeah you're working like three jobs at
the time right yeah it was i was i was
super busy but then i finally got into a
position where i could you know focus
completely on what i'm doing now so i'm
very lucky i'm very lucky and um i'm
glad that it turned out that way because
yeah i definitely would have died which
is ironic considering who i am so it
would have been a bad situation um but
interestingly enough i feel now that i'm
like controlling my own schedule i'm
busier than i was before
yeah yeah yeah because you're you're
filling in all the blanks that's how it
works you're like oh i have one second
free at this moment perhaps
yeah i remember last time talking to you
you were just like yeah i'm working
three jobs um i you know i kind of feel
bad if i quit one and like i think it
took a month for you to realize yeah
that's just not doable
that was a bad idea just impossible
it's a good thing to honor your
commitment yeah there's also a point
where honoring your commitments actively
[ __ ] yourself over yeah so you know you
can always just be like ah this just
isn't working out for me uh i'm gonna
i'm gonna not do this yeah i think last
time you're on the podcast you had like
i think 300 000 subs or something like
that yeah how long have you been doing
uh v tubing at that point how long has
that been i think it had only been about
like two or three months since we all
had debuted together yeah you were a
baby back then i remember like like i
think hololive english just got
announced a few months before we started
filming that episode so it was like
super super fresh and now you're at like
how many subs now i think uh we just hit
one million seven hundred and fifty
thousand subscribers recently
i don't know
[Applause]
i do think a lot of it has to do with my
music personally um oh yeah yeah because
um i think that that's where the
majority of my fans come from in fact i
see a lot of comments these days saying
i don't really know what a youtuber is
but i like maury's music so that's good
um that's always i'm happy to see that
as well does it does it feel like a year
or does it feel like five years you know
it's like it changes every day like
every day i feel a different way about
it like i feel like um maybe for example
yesterday i was reflecting back and i'm
like man time has gone by so fast but
the previous week i was like
man what a long year it's been have i
been doing this for five years maybe
yeah youtube is like a reverse
hyperbolic time chamber yeah yeah it is
it's like oh god i feel like i've done
this for a decade it's like oh it's been
two months oh [ __ ] all right
yeah some sometimes as a youtuber it
feels like five years or five months i
can't tell sometimes i mean it must feel
like [ __ ] ages
i've been thinking of this for how long
now i feel like i've like aged a hundred
years on youtube my god
there's some ogs that's for sure yeah
yeah i'll call them oh sorry um i
completely forgot what i was going to
say now i'm sorry
come on we've been doing this for how
many episodes now that hurts bad host
no problem man but i do have to say
though one thing that has really made it
seem like it's been a long time is
realizing just how little i knew at the
beginning
yeah yeah how much have you learned oh
god i mean honestly to be to be
completely real you guys you know as i
mentioned before i did a lot of music
stuff before this as well um but i feel
like this year i've put out more content
than i have in my entire career before
this year oh yeah yeah um and i really
learned a lot about like work ethic and
um you know what it means to
consistently put out content every
single day
yeah that's something you don't really
think about when you get into the online
like online creation field right is that
you kind of have to it is a job and you
have to schedule your job just call
garnet just call them out
that's like content
i feel like everyone has a different
like interpretation of what content
consists of
you know
she's learning
[Laughter]
it really depends on the person like for
example
i've seen plenty of requests for a
sleeping stream yeah um that's not
really what i'm interested in but i've
seen plenty of others do it and i guess
how's that going well you've done that
you've done that yeah you know when i
see youtubers sleep i'm like oh that's
cheating that's yeah you get like like
come on unless unless there's a chance
that you could expose your bear ass i
feel like it's not really well there's
no danger there you know right yeah i i
feel like as a victor you could uh cheat
the system
right
you know the model can just kind of prop
you know you have this wonderful ability
where you're not saying you would do
that no
of course of course
you can call it like it is fine
youtubers have this amazing ability that
when they're not there they can still be
there yeah yeah so i feel like it kind
of takes away some of the magic of
sleight of hand yeah just sleep in
another room
you just put on a sleep track like
snoring in the background yeah yeah yeah
it's me i'm actually in another room i
mean it's scary though what if you sleep
talk you know you can't risk okay i did
i didn't okay i didn't mute my mic just
because i yeah you know i didn't want to
take
[Music]
i recently went on a a trip with chris
and he said that i woke up at night and
just like shouted and then like woke up
and then she went back to bed i shouted
are you okay i do that that happens yeah
it happens really yeah do you guys know
w's in my dream i'm sorry what can i say
do you guys snore at all
when you sleep i want to tell you no but
let's be honest i probably do yeah you
definitely do okay you definitely do
yeah um yeah all right
i remember it i think it was the
drifting special where someone was
snoring bad on the drifting special
because like
let's just blame chris anyway he's he's
not here let's let's defend himself
no the you always have that one friend
who just like is the snore of the group
and it's it's always like a time limit
it's always like a race to get to sleep
before that guy starts snoring right
there's like multiple snorers there's
always like two level one people and
then there's like one level 100 person
oh you're clearly making like 90 of the
noise what i what i hate is when there's
two people who like normally they're
just like level one snorers but like for
some reason when they sleep together
they feed into each other right it's the
resonance of the snoring
and it becomes like this like horrible
cacophony of like snoring actually how
do you know if you're snore though
that's the question
well usually like a partner tells you my
significant half tells me yeah same yeah
i'm just like i'm not recording myself
asleep
yeah has anyone ever told you if you
snore or if you sleep
sleep talk or anything like that i went
on a trip with uh kiara a while ago we
went to hokkaido and she said that i
just talked so much in my sleep i do
that two times she was like one night
you sounded sad like you were crying
then one night you were laughing and it
was horrifying
wow those bars are just like constantly
coming right
i just i just performed the entirety of
rap god
you're like an oracle to the right
i mean i guess i could at this point i
did practice that song a lot it's like
she's speaking oh can you can you
perform rap god now let's see uh some
alum of the malama you assuming i'm a
human what i gotta do to get through to
you i'm super human innovative and i'm
making my uh
i don't have the lyrics in front of me
oh that was pretty [ __ ] impressive
they've been lying to me then i've known
godzilla rap god and the poker wrap and
interestingly enough the most difficult
of all of them was the poker app oh yeah
yeah
yeah
how do you pronounce gyarados like is it
is it gyarados
gyarados
that's the interesting thing is that i
went on uh google sensei who told me
that the pronunciation is different uh
in american english and uh
uk english really how do you say it i
say gyarados but i know they say
gyarados or something like that yeah
it's like
what the [ __ ] the [ __ ] is that i said
garrett i said gyarados yeah
because in japanese it's gyarados yeah i
know i'll just take it from there i know
but uh i mean this we're talking about
i've always got it from the english dub
which i swear they say gyarados but the
irish stuff is never consistent but
we're all so stupid we're british
i remember i remember like in the
english because there was like another
one that always gets heatly debated is
uh do you say groudon or do you say
grunon a groudon i've always thought
because in the anime they said two
different times i'm gonna show my age
now what's grew down
is that one of the newer pokemon
it's the same gen that like rayquaza
oh
that's yeah ruby sapphire yeah okay
and groudon is like the the
the guy on the front of the ruby cover
like that okay
yeah that's the blue one called uh
kyogre yeah kyogre it's it's the [ __ ]
uh stingray right
that's just not a memorable name for me
right like lugia that's an easy name to
remember
like uh zapdos easy name to remember
like [ __ ] ruby sapphire past they're
just like i swear they're just using
welsh you know it's just like
how am i supposed to remember this i
mean you do not want to play the newer
ones the newer ones are like do you like
clef key
he's like you know you know clef key
right which one is that it's the keys
it's literally the pair of keys the pair
of keys
it's my favorite [ __ ] pokemon yeah
it's like an actual like strong pokemon
for like troll yeah like oh that's kind
of cool steel steel fairy tale yeah i
feel like they just dropped a ball on
the keyboard and i'm just like yeah okay
that's the pokemon name now
uh garba dose
garbage dose
garbage pokemon
yeah garbage
it's the garbage pokemon
it's a trash bag with hands and
legs yeah
it's [ __ ] awesome
there's an ice cream one too oh yeah
vanilla ice yeah never out of ideas
no not vanilla eyes
that's a wrap isn't it i was gonna say
this he's not a character from jokes
[Music]
see that's why the poker app is so hard
though because i'll think that i got
through it i'll be like oh yeah pidgeot
and then the chat will just be full of
it's pidgeot you dummy
uh i guess we'll be starting over again
great that's the second to last name in
the poker wraps
all the way over how long is the poker
app because i assume you did the full
version with
50 yeah all
think it's like three minutes but it
feels like 30.
they put it at the end of the episode
yeah but they only put like a small
snippet yeah oh did they yeah yeah it's
only like half of them i think the full
one is like three four minutes online
it's about three to four minutes but you
know the hardest part is remembering how
to pronounce everything without people
being like hey
that ain't right the one line that
always stuck with me during the poker
rap because like i grew up with that
[ __ ] is uh
did you perform a properly cali where
it's like the last line is like
charmeleon and then it's warthor war
torture yeah they it's like they got
like a metal singer and it's like
only that part though it's like
chameleons like
oh my god [ __ ] it what happened with
waterfalls
the stream my chat was really excited
about that one part yeah yeah yeah i
didn't know the baby beard appears out
of nowhere
i didn't know this rap song required
like a [ __ ] death growl and like a
metal singer
that's a fun song though it's a fun song
yeah because like i remember
i remember always trying to like learn
the poker app when i was younger and i
can't rap yeah as we've all established
good money to watch your childhood gone
in his mirror trying to sing the pokemon
wrap i would pay a lot of money for that
pleasure how many pokemon are there
nowadays seven hundred and something
yeah
at which point do you guys recognize all
the pokemon
no i think i'm i know what gen they're
from yeah i i can tell you what jen
they're from but i couldn't tell you
their names yeah the name's like
impossible the names are like hard mode
but yeah didn't uh who's that youtuber
brian the guy who's polygon oh brian
david gilbert he made a new poker that
had like all of them yeah it was [ __ ]
insane yeah like he he like splits up to
three separate like parts of the song
basically my god he did like every
pokemon it was [ __ ] insane
he performed it live as well at a panel
which is like even more insane holy [ __ ]
the pokemon now is 898. yeah super
boomers you even being charged now 890
wow that's a lot i'm curious you've been
streaming now for like over over a year
now
what are some of the
fun streams that you've done like the
unique ones that have already stood out
in your yeah i'm curious because i want
to know what kind of streams you join
what is your favorite content that you
can produce content
content quote unquote content um i did a
staring contest one time wait how does
that wait what you did yeah so i was at
a friend's house that i hadn't seen in a
while and i really couldn't reschedule
hanging out with her so um i went to the
bathroom in the morning
and um i took my laptop i took my usb
microphone i pulled myself real up close
to the camera and i did a staring
contest with everyone and um it did
really well actually there were a lot of
people
how long did that last about an hour but
see it kind of devolved it wasn't
entirely only me staring at everyone in
the beginning i started off like being
just kind of like sleepy and quite
frankly a bit rude um to everyone in
chat i feel a little bad about that but
then afterwards we got on to some fun
content quote unquote content i actually
went and um i found some some old uh
copy pastas to try and read without
cracking a smile um on the stream
and um i got through i got through shrek
i got through um
actually the answer is
like a genius yeah
yeah yeah um the one that got me though
i don't know if you guys know this one
of all the ones to get me the one that
got me was uh club penguin is kill oh
yeah i love that one i love that one
what is that one
i think you got it can you perform it
if i could pull it up on my phone i'd
i'd do it for you
but
we need to get it up what is it is it a
copy pasta is it a meme what is it yes
it's like a tweet actually oh okay okay
thanks
a live
yeah a live reading of club penguin and
i'll try not to laugh this time because
it actually wasn't the copy pasta itself
that got me to laugh it was chat
um
all right here's my live reading
here we go
this is from sergeant arch doornan who
left um
a tweet
about the club penguin after it shut
down
um apolgi for bad english
where were you when club penguin died
i was at house eating dorito
when phone ring
club penguin is killed
why is it fun
what is what is it
[Music]
the saddest part is the part that got me
to laugh was just everyone in chat
saying no
thank you very much magic reading
absolutely i mean that's the first copy
pastor we've had on trash take hell yeah
you guys don't get in trouble for this
oh no no no
should i sneak back the phone right
through the void
there we go it's like how do you think
up of ideas for streams because one
thing about stream is that how often do
you stream every week uh it depends i
really started to try and get more into
five streams a week when i was focusing
more on music but october has been
really busy because you know it's
halloween it's my favorite month i am
the grim reaper so i've been
i've been doing like seven to nine a
week um
seven to nine streams a week yes is that
a stream every day uh yeah you know
there's seven days in a week
well sometimes i'll clump them together
because the way i see it is if i can get
one day off where i don't have to worry
about anything that's great but if i can
like do two streams at once in a day
it's like i can get all of it and you're
doing music on top of this as well
what what the [ __ ]
yeah it's fun well i mean i like
streaming a lot it's great but my my
passion at the end of all of it is music
and i can't i can't resist doing that um
of course
how'd you think up of nine different
streams a week does it like
do do you like sometimes is it easy do
you have like an idea that you fall back
on or does it get like tiring having to
think up of like variety streams these
different things i think john can only
think of nine videos a year right yeah
yeah yeah yeah i was gonna say yeah
that's like [ __ ] fake fake
[ __ ] how many fake videos
enough it's a situation where um i keep
thinking of things that i want to stream
in that week and then i end up clogging
up my schedule so they're just a lot of
games that i want to play there was a
situation where i ordered the wii u four
different times i finally got it um yeah
so let me explain let me explain how
this went down so i ordered a wii u um
while i was in america uh so that i
could have it shipped and then i could
take it back with me uh to japan so that
i could play earthbound because i've
been really trying to do an earthbound
playthrough um on stream and so i got
that but it arrived too late um in
america i was already in japan so then i
ordered one to come to japan a japanese
one i thought you could change the
language to english you cannot
so that didn't work out everything i
read on the internet was a lie about
that so um i gave to a friend um and
then after that i ordered one on ebay
from america uh they tried to deliver it
to my house after one failed delivery
attempt sent it back to america uh so
finally finally i got one off of amazon
that they were willing to ship to japan
and it arrived
and finally i have a freaking wii u
um
yeah but back to the question there are
too many things that i want to do um
earthbound on the stream oh but i gotta
finish playing doom eternal oh but
there's other there's this other game
that i want to play wait a minute we
just got permission for this
i want to stream this before anyone else
kind of thing you know um
two different people want to do a
collaboration well i always love doing
collabs with people that reach out to me
so let's do it everyone's been asking
for a minecraft stream let's play
minecraft you know i haven't done a
chatting stream in a while i want to let
everyone know what's going on i want to
talk about my new song that just came
out i mean i haven't done an asmr stream
in a while it's just all these ideas
come to me and i'm like man i wish i
could be this full of ideas man
i mean it's a bit of a stressor though i
really should learn to spread things out
more often i just get real excited about
i have an idea let's do it now
well it sounds like you've gone from
like three part-time jobs to working
three part-time jobs in one job so yeah
it does feel like that when you're on
charge your own schedule it gets to be
like that sometimes yeah i i saw that
you got uh you are doing a convention
appearance yes oh yeah yeah is it is it
is it almost strange doing it virtually
as opposed to irl that's a good question
um
it does feel a little unreal sometimes
but then once i see like all the fans
gathering together yeah it all starts to
settle down and i'm like oh man this is
a real thing wow people really like us
and uh yeah i think once we started like
for example doing the um the fan expo
panels that was when i kind of started
to realize like how many really how many
fans we have and uh it made it all super
real for me so that was good do i feel a
bit sad that you can never interact with
them directly is that yeah yeah because
to us that's like a big part of us going
to conventions right do you yeah
i mean i hope that there's a day where
that kind of thing can happen i mean i
have a friend i've talked about on the
stream before milky queen she does
things like that um going to conventions
and can actually like meet full body in
front of like a green screen in front of
um
in front of the fans
they can touch the screen and like
high-five her and stuff like that and
that's something i'd love to do i don't
really know if if that's something that
holo can accomplish right now but i
think it would be amazing
technology these days man
everyone getting beyond where the haptic
suits yeah
that's right what was it called like the
metaverse or whatever like is that what
like facebook is that what like facebook
are trying to
develop or something yeah
basically facebook just make youtubers
because that will like that will make
the interest just like 10 times more
yeah oh for sure yeah well interestingly
enough we did do a vr stream um myself
and all of the myth myth girls we did uh
for our anniversary we all got into vr
chat and um we actually all bought the
suits to like track our movements and
stuff like that and
we went in as like small versions of
ourselves i saw this yeah yeah yeah that
was so fun and it just it made me want
to meet with the others even more so
that we can really fully debut someday
in 3d is it weird wearing like the full
tracking suit
what what is the four tracking suits is
it the one like the mocap is it the
actual mocap suits or is it the one
where you it's like on the i think it's
like i think it's like once it's like
two on the hands two on the feet and
then like one on your waist yeah yeah
yeah yeah you track your waist movements
i had a little too much fun with that
though with all the tracks
moving around maybe a little too much
probably could have dialed it back a bit
but i was so excited to like be in a 3d
space able to move with my friends you
know yeah vr is definitely the first
time you're like holy [ __ ] and then you
realize that you're like sweating a lot
and then you've burnt like 10 000
calories so you're having so much fun
have you played this game called gorilla
tag
it's
on the topic of vr uh so connor connor
had his housewarming party the other day
and uh chris was there and uh seeing
chris try vr for the first time was a
[ __ ] sight to begin we gave chris a
few drinks and i was like
i was like drinks i was like chris uh
you should try playing super hot
[Laughter]
and christmas so upset i missed out dude
he was like rolling on the floor doing
like jumps and [ __ ] like like james bond
in my bedroom smacking the walls like
nearly broke all my jojo's first thing i
see i walk in and chris is like [ __ ]
[ __ ] punching someone he punches like
joe a jojo poster right there broke it
like he's full-on punching and vr like
i'm like chris it's okay
my god nearly destroyed my apartment
he was like what is this [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
he put it on he loved it it's classic
chris that's vr right it's like i've
tried to talk so many people into vr and
they're just like nah i don't get it
it's probably not for me it's definitely
one of those things that you just have
to try
and it's like once you try it then you
fully understand like you could give a
[ __ ] dissertation on why vr is
awesome and you probably couldn't get i
mean like the thing about vr is that i i
can only play vr for a certain amount of
time before i just
just feels less casual you know i don't
know i swear a lot you gotta play you
gotta play gorilla tag that's where the
real what's gorilla type how do you play
it's exactly what it sounds like your
gorillas and you tag each other oh boy i
did it on stream right um i thought it
would just be like chasing people yeah
turns out it's just like 10 year olds
just like
playing as a gorillas what do you mean
it's like it's all 10 year olds i joined
a lobby and 10 year olds are like
swearing and saying horrible things and
i was like so it's just xbox live
if you want to export go and play
gorilla tag right because what happens
is the way conor gets to relive his
childhood that's why he loves you so
much
i did not like this i realized the power
you have as a kid is unobtainable as an
adult those kids could say and do
anything and i can't i can't say that
[ __ ] back to them it's just so unfair
the kid the kids can say whatever they
want and it's like i mean it's unfair
i want to be able to call that kid a
little [ __ ] why not why can't you call
that i'm on stream i can't say it off
stream i'll say
on your behalf yeah yeah please come in
and just what were they what were they
saying to you they were saying words
that you cannot say on stream okay
you know what you streaming and i was
streaming there's a clip of me i go in i
go in a world i join it and one of the
kids is saying the word that you cannot
say yeah and i was like all right then
gonna go away and then just left the
world because
this ten-year-old kid was screaming it
but it's really fun right so you do is
you have the controllers and you they
act like it sounds like a bunch of apes
in there yeah yes precisely
so you have two two of the vr
controllers right yeah and those are
your your legs and your arms so when you
want to move you have to like jump with
the the legs oh yeah yeah
right and people are insane at it these
kids are insane they're like flying
across the map and i can barely move i
really felt like a boomer
you should play gorilla tag
oh how how long do you play vr for
though how long did you stream for three
hours four hours
did you all get sweaty because that's
extremely strong okay that's that's
that's what puts me off vr it's like i
stream for like i play for an hour i get
really sweaty and then you you take you
you don't take the vr self you [ __ ]
peel it off for that at that point right
but it just just doesn't feel good at
least the index has the um removable
face thing yeah so you can like clean it
so i didn't feel too disgusted by it
right so you're just like cycling
through the foam the foam parts i'm like
cleaning it a lot okay which headset are
you using oh i'm using the uh valve
index okay so yeah yeah yeah yeah super
good i hate wires though i hate that why
is the only thing that like take you out
of it i feel like yeah i feel like
once it once it gets like wireless
headsets that are like high quality then
i would get more invested into vr oculus
2 right is like the the wireless one
right yeah i think it's not as the specs
aren't as good as the index though but i
mean it's still it's pretty good from
what i've heard yeah i haven't streamed
on my oculus 2 yet but just i bought it
just because i heard that there's no
wires i'm like yeah good this is these
the index is like super easy to use
was that the first time you tried vr or
had you tried vr before your stream ah
yeah actually to be honest i kind of
wasn't interested at all in it but you
know emilia is like the the tech wizard
um in myth and she was just kind of like
hey what if we did a big vr collab for
our anniversary and all of us were like
okay but how and she's like no it's
super easy and she told us everything we
needed to buy that sounds like a
technical nightmare
oh my god
oh my god
imagine trying to like schedule that and
sort that [ __ ] out i go through enough
technical issues just like streaming
just streaming on my pc on my own let
alone like doing a cross-continental vr
stream oh my god
motion capture she worked really hard
i'm curious is there anything with
being a v tuber over the past year that
you've learned is like
annoyingly difficult that other people
would just never consider oh let me
think this is a tough one
um
one sec no worries nothing because there
are a lot of things that are good
because i feel like i don't appreciate
how difficult it can be sometimes yeah i
just look at them and i just think oh
wow you guys don't have to worry about
how you look you can just
channel the model that's great i'm so
jealous i mean there's a lot of stuff
you know behind the scenes that we have
to do is the thing oh yeah a lot of
people you know they see us for like um
maybe like two three hours if you stream
for a short amount of time if you do
like an endurance stream eight hours
sure but here's the thing though when we
we press like go live and like after
we're done stop the stream immediately
what i do is i go sit on the couch and i
start making thumbnails i make a bunch
of thumbnails for the week then i have
to make the schedule which you know last
night took about an hour and a half so
so you make the thumbnails yourself yes
oh my god i think i think most youtubers
do right what
that's the one thing i'm so impressed
with youtubers is that they always have
like unique thumbnails for everything
and i'm like i didn't realize how
grateful i am that twitch you don't have
to do that how did you learn how to do
that because like like
not not to be like a dumb question but
thumbnails are like a very fine arts
that you a lot of youtubers learn as
they go along i mean i didn't know how
to make no i didn't know how to make
good thumbnails until like a year or two
after i'd start doing i mean there's
people on the platform that have been on
for like 10 years that still don't know
how to make it yeah yeah yeah exactly i
mean it's something that you just kind
of learn along the way because for me i
had no idea my thumbnail game was real
week before but i had to get good at it
you know and i started kind of seeing
what others did as well and not
completely taking everything that
everyone did but little things here and
there that i'd i noticed and be like i
should i should do like a stroke layer
on this text like this and it'll look a
lot better and a drop shadow here and
that kind of stuff and it's all just
like fine fine little things you'd never
really think super hard about but they
do make a difference yeah exactly how
long do you guys spend in your
thumbnails
um i try to do it as little as possible
yeah i try and outsource it as much
see this guy's working smart i think i
spend maybe like max 30 minutes
i'm quite short when it comes to
something i i feel like if you have the
capacity to pay someone else to do
something you should pay someone else to
do something
no but like there's it's work it's
business i want more time to do my stuff
no exactly but for some people they
value the truth sound privilege i know
[ __ ] yeah shut up you're pretty chad
laughing at me
yeah i mean the thing is uh for example
for v tubers there are so many of them
that want to be in control of their own
thumbnails that like it becomes a
creativity thing i feel like thumbnails
are important because with you you've
got an artist doing a lot of your
thumbnails and aside from that it's like
taking the perfect shot on scene or
something whereas my thumbnails can take
up to like some some thumbnails i can
outsource some icon because even i don't
know how to market some of my videos
right i don't know for me like when when
you upload twice a week or
recently once a month you need to make
that [ __ ]
no thumbnail sorry twice a month twice a
month uh
once every two weeks you need to make
those thumbnails count like with trash
taste it's just like easy if if one
thumbnail doesn't hit you go next week
with me i'm just like if this thumbnail
doesn't hit i'm gonna wait a [ __ ]
month man like that [ __ ] hurts
have you thought about perhaps uploading
more often
well that means
that means making content that's it it's
faster to make yeah yeah
you know there's less pressure on making
that perfect thumbnail all right i am
making as much content as i possibly can
joy please okay
i mean i think another thing that people
also don't realize is um one big factor
is just
simply um
the energy it takes to be you all the
time yeah yeah um when i'm putting up a
schedule for a new stream i gotta put in
a description that i think kind of you
know either matches or is this too much
am i saying too many things in the
description you overthink a lot in this
channel am i gonna put out a tweet that
like says a lot of things or like one
sentence a couple words you have to
always think about this kind of stuff
you know and um scheduling meetings as
well that's another big thing it's
interesting that you mentioned about
description and
uh tags i guess and the tweet and
everything because i i think over the
six years what i've learned is that i
just don't care about any of that now
and i do you care about your description
anymore no i i used to care right and
then i found out that like all the big
channels just don't do any of that they
don't put anything in the tags i think
my experience there's two things that
matters title thumbnail
that's literally the only real thing you
need to worry about tags and stuff and
descriptions and stuff it doesn't help
as much anymore and like i i know this
now because have you guys gone through
this issue recently with youtube right
where you search for us
you search for a certain video right and
then the first three searches are
pertaining to that search and then for
some reason after about five searches it
just goes back to your recommendations
nowadays i'm just like what is the point
of the search function anymore if the
first five videos aren't what i'm
searching for then i'm just [ __ ] or
it's like viewers of your channel also
do you think it's like i don't care
yeah that's not what that's literally
not what i searched for it's
it's gotten to the point where you know
back when youtube started it's just like
it's just like okay i subscribe to the
channels i want to watch youtube's like
no no no you don't want to watch these
channels these channels and i'm like
okay maybe i get recommendations yeah
now it's just like i want to search for
a specific video and youtube's like no
no no no no no no no no no no no you
don't want to search for that you don't
watch these videos so one of the ones
that annoy me the most is like after the
fifth search it's like here's a new
video from someone you're subscribed i'm
like what is the point of the
subscription
what is the point of pages now because
all pages are just going to become the
same page eventually exactly
so annoying like what is the point of
the search bar so yeah like to me like
descriptions and tags don't mean as much
anymore it's it's all about title
thumbnail viewer retention because it's
all recommendations we all bow down to
the almighty algorithm yeah and that's
and that's unfortunately like
that's unfortunately what you've got to
do to be a youtuber nowadays yeah pretty
much i mean i guess it does make sense
that it should be you know what you say
and what you create and not necessarily
what you're typing into the description
right i mean every time that i see for
example some of my gem mates they just
throw up a schedule nothing in the
description i'm like wow what a bunch of
chads
it doesn't matter but i mean i don't
know i guess i'm still there's still
some things i'm figuring out you know
day by day i've gotten a lot better than
i was in the past um and i feel good
about that so you know day by day though
you can always learn new stuff
especially in this job i feel like
you've won like a shitload in just a
year
considering
what you've learned in this year and
what you've done in this year it's
actually insane yeah compared to i look
back on some of the years i've had on
youtube and i'm just like i'm doing
[ __ ] nothing how do you mainly would
you say you learn things on streaming
and youtube is it did you learn from
other
gen mates or do you learn from outside
of uh hollow live or do you learn all on
yourself i'm curious
where you kind of pick up this stuff a
lot of times it's like a feeling that i
get like after i'm done with a stream i
can feel whether it was bad or good oh
no yeah i agree
what i did wrong this technically wasn't
good these people were angry about this
etc and it's on my mind you know and i
also i'm very receptive to criticism but
something that i also learned is that
not every criticism that you get that is
framed politely is necessarily correct
that's a lie that we tell ourselves to
so that we don't come off as butt hurt
babies but the truth of the matter is
you don't need to 100 take every single
critique that you get from every
anonymous person on the internet even if
it's framed nicely you need to be able
to discern
what is actually going to help you and
what isn't but one thing that you
shouldn't do is lash out i would say
that that's oh yeah yeah that's a given
yeah never feed the trolls
just never ends up well you know there
are people that get excited uh when i
talk about them than the bad things they
say and the thing that you do is you
don't give it to them and you just
ignore it yeah i mean yeah it's rule
number one don't yeah don't forget the
truth that was another thing to learn as
well along the way you get did you get
like when you started off did you did
you get like a lot of advice from maybe
your fellow gen mates or you know cover
itself about
what to do in terms of like how to
handle your content and just like
general advice to be a content creator
in general was it all just like trial by
fire uh
you know
you know i'm gonna be honest with you
we really were just kind of they just
said go you know and i think that part
of that is because in the process of
selecting us they made sure that we
would be okay with that because all of
us that have like gone through it
have not there hasn't been like a huge
disaster or anything like that with us
in terms of streaming everyone has a
good handle on themselves and i think
you got to give it to um to uh i guess
who chose us
for that uh specifically that they did
choose people that have a handle on how
to do things however that isn't to say
that we were all experienced streamers
in the beginning yeah that's definitely
not the case i had barely streamed in my
entire life i was mostly making music in
the shadows yeah yeah quite different
you know extremely different but but
somehow they knew that i'd be able to
handle it somehow and you learn a lot of
things along the way but in the
beginning we all did have the ability to
get through that starting line you know
but we didn't get a lot of advice i will
be honest with you i think one of the
biggest things you have to learn which a
lot of people maybe might not consider
is the technical side of things because
like with a youtube video you know if
something technical happens on sale or
something some things you could kind of
save and post
there is no getting around technical
issues on stream and i feel like the
only way you've really learned is when
it happens on stream and you're just
like well i guess i just have to learn
not to do that again right exactly stuff
breaks a lot as well yeah
right
yeah damn so you mainly
did a lot of it on your own you learned
everything
wow so when you when you started off
there was nobody who was like hey by the
way people might just say like bad
things about you for like no reason that
might just happen just like it's gonna
happen no one told you there was a
question um
that i will i will say because it's kind
of obvious that they would ask us this
okay um
people are going to say mean things
about you and hate you are you okay with
that and obviously all of us got in
we all said yes but i remember a
question
my answer specifically was well i've
dealt with that with my music before um
you know before all of all of this i did
indeed have people that would come
around and do a little bit of trolling
so to speak um and
i felt like i had dealt with them pretty
well by just not saying anything and i
feel like um i thought to myself i
should be fine when i enter holo and
it's been fine um so that's okay for me
um you know everyone's experience though
is different i would say so yeah i i
think as well there is the
added uh very scary aspect of being uh
what again this is just my perception of
being a youtuber everyone is just like
trying to find out as much personal
information right yeah yeah whereas
everyone can just see that i'm a
teenager now and
i feel like although people are
definitely trying you know people try
and get our personal information but i
don't feel like it's intense yeah like
at least i don't see it maybe i'm just
too lazy i'm not looking but yeah
or you've already shown everything
because like one one thing i've always
been curious about is like do you feel
pressure to have to keep like say a
certain image of yourself or you know
your audience or just the general
perception of youtubers because we we
obviously keep a certain image but i
don't i feel like it's nothing on the
same level as what youtubers have to go
through right
it's rough because i feel like one thing
that i learned is at the end of the day
i've got maybe about 80 of a fan base
that really really want me to be 100
just myself i see them in the comments
all the time saying you're doing great
callie just you know loosen up a little
bit in the beginning right for example
you guys saw when i first came here i
was i was trying to be something that i
wasn't like
um yeah it was quite strange but it
turned out good it was not it was good
it was a good episode of my development
we literally saw the development on the
two-hour podcast exactly exactly and so
you know
for those for those people saying just
be yourself kelly i gotta say thank you
because it was because of comments like
that that i realized hey maybe it's okay
for me to loosen up a little bit relax
you know people wanna see who i am for
who i am and that's great but of course
you're gonna get you know a small but
loud minority of people that want you to
be a certain way and you just gotta deal
with it i personally have found um i
think like a happy medium where i'm
still being myself but i'm not you know
going into territory that would make
others angry you know
like viciously angry you know of course
because i feel like when comments tell
you to be yourself it's kind of like a
trap because like they want they want
you to be yourself but not yourself
don't like i'm just like the worst
person
yeah
go
back i think i think when they say you
should just be yourself they what they
actually mean is be yourself
but the version that i like yeah exactly
right exactly
but i try to look at it in like a
positive light you know and just do the
best that i can to be
the best me and um and just stay
positive i've found that uh negativity
tripped me up a lot in the beginning and
um
i've been i've been trying to you know
smile through even the difficult times i
know it sounds cheesy anime as hell i
guess
small small food of
[Laughter]
yeah definitely um but i feel like a
positive outlook is good and necessary
if you want to keep doing this for a
long time
so i feel like things have gone pretty
well and i'll just keep all i can keep
doing is being the best me because at
the end of the day no matter what
someone's going to be angry at you for
something and if people are constantly
going to be like be this way be this way
and constantly upset at the choices that
you make why not make the choice that
you want to make and just deal with it
from there yeah you know it's nice
because when i'm
when we met you on the podcast i didn't
really know of your streams at all i've
seen it a little bit
and definitely now even throughout the
year when i check in it seems like every
single time i've watched your streams
you just seem more comfortable and more
yeah
i think you got further than me and jump
king as well oh yeah i've been i've been
grinding on that that jump king that is
painful absolutely have you played jump
king no i've been trying to get like a
bunch of people
with me though because i really want to
play it it's like you don't want to go
on champions
oh we should we should race it together
on stream well i only played like two
hours i'm down to play
i've got it i've got to take a wild
guess what you're doing
you jump up you can't
you know before i agree to this i could
be agreeing to like a [ __ ] suicide
pact brian are we jumping off a cliff
is that what jump
best way to experience it in my opinion
just going blind because that's what
happened to me what's the game with the
pickaxe and the no no no no no we're
getting over it yeah imagine over it
imagine getting over it with jumping
yeah that's literally it yeah have you
played getting over it
no benefit he's getting over you know
what gets the guy it's the naked guy in
the pot you have to use the pickaxe to
get to the top of the mouth oh yeah i
know that like imagine that but jumping
imagine that but jumping yeah okay yeah
and you're a kid okay
and you can just fold it's got really
good pixel art as well okay the art is
amazing yeah but it is journal jump it's
basically doodle jump it's doodle jump
over the game with getting over it yeah
okay it is rough it is very difficult
but the way that i've gotten around it
is i've started jumping into voice chat
uh with my with a whole live club
but i've been sitting in voice chat just
waiting i've just been waiting for um
other members to jump in and have a
little chat with me and um the time flew
by i got into chat and two of the other
members iris and bay just jumped into
voice chat and we just talked about
anime the whole time that i was
suffering trying to climb this building
and eight hours just flew by it was
amazing oh yeah well yeah i mean i guess
without it it's like you're basically in
solitary confinement right yeah exactly
sounds horrible it's a horrible that's
why i want to erase it right so i can
distract myself by talking [ __ ] to other
people so what is the point of jumping
is there like an energy
jump jump to the top save the princess
thank you for explaining to me what jump
king is like i have a general idea now
i would like to try streaming that okay
don't get my hopes up
all of you race in jump king yeah we
should you can be the mc all right
gotcha i'll narrate the whole thing
so is it like gets over it where it's
easy to reach or where it's like really
hard to reach the end in one place yeah
and it's really easy to just like fall
down and fall to the bottom yeah you
could have been playing for like five
hours and you've made it so many levels
up and then just one wrong fall leads to
a chain of more wrong falls that put you
down at the very first stage and then
you get tilted and then you start just
throwing you can't remember how to jump
in the certain places that you were
jumping before you just run into a blind
rage after a while love it can't wait
can't wait it's great it's really going
to test your monk mode skills for sure
oh my god yeah what's like your favorite
type of content to make then is it
playing games or is it like
interacting with the chat ah let's see
you know interestingly enough i felt
like my my interaction skills with chat
were kind of non-existent in the
beginning um to be completely honest is
because i was a big old baby um
especially towards the beginning big old
baby big old baby
terrifying right knowing that i'm bad at
video games i was really kind of scared
to check the chat because i didn't want
to lose you know energy and momentum by
seeing someone say hey you suck because
while i while i'm aware i'm not very
good at video games it's like seeing
everyone telling you how to do a certain
thing
even if i can hold back a reaction or a
snarky remark it does bring down the
energy a bit and i want to stay high
energy you know so it's something i had
to learn to do to like really kind of
put up a wall between you know
people leaving you know funny comments
or like just general feedback and people
screaming at you in all caps uh that you
should be using a pickaxe to to break
stones instead of a shovel which is i
will say that is a good piece of advice
and i appreciate it that's a good piece
of life advice
when it's not in all caps the same thing
applies in real
that life that is true um i'm more
likely to listen to it if it's phrased
not in all caps though that's a general
just a good idea for for jet i would say
in general i don't really actually care
too much about backseating it's like
it's when it gets to be everyone and
super aggressive that my energy begins
to fall so i had to kind of learn to
like hey callie get over it just you
know try and try and like
like turn your vision into a way that it
can just pick out
comments and chat that like that aren't
entirely aggressive and you keep the
stream going and so i do like
interacting with chat these days uh chad
can be funny they have some they have
some jokes yeah yeah you guys have jokes
out there i will say um and they really
do kind of brighten up my day so it's
been worth it um in the end but i'd say
my favorite kinds of streams to do
probably variety streams though they do
take the most preparation
recently i've been trying to do eikaiwa
streams so like english learning by
speaking simple and slow english for
anyone really not only japanese viewers
but people around the world who maybe
have english as a second language um
that takes a lot of preparation when you
said english learning i was like you
learning english
i think you've already got that down
you know you should do a dueling english
speed run see how see how good you are
in english
i feel like i would be way worse than i
i think i have any right to be at
english
i feel like i don't know that's that's
an interesting stream actually so you're
seeing if you are as fluent in english
as you're like something like duolingo
thinks you are yeah
what's what's the main language then
that you have the application set on if
you're learning english does it have to
be can it be english again
i guess that's a good question
i don't think duolingo has ever thought
about that before so you know uh this is
gonna sound so bad so what you know i'm
learning japanese right yeah and they're
like oh yeah it's like a it's it's like
a pronoun and i was like yeah
for the first time i hear i was like
what is that again
i was like what's the foreign i know but
like you know what you hear actually
like i haven't heard that been you know
when you're on different types of verbs
and nouns you're like wait hold on let
me refresh my memory of what that is
again hold up it's been like five years
ago i remember what a problem is
we know you know when you they because
because they obviously think when when
the japanese teacher is teaching me
japanese they're like oh you know this
stuff it's english it's fluent you speak
it right and it's like yeah yeah i
remember that stuff i remember
absolutely i don't think that works when
it comes to learning languages though to
me at least when i hear something as a
pronoun i don't think i remember well as
as we've just established we don't know
what the [ __ ] pronoun is isn't in is
in our own language how the [ __ ] are we
going to learn that in another language
it's so embarrassing when i'm there in
front of the teacher who is japanese and
she's like oh it's just like this thing
and i'm like yeah
i know what that is yeah exactly i'm
like totally i know what that is
okay i know what an adjective is
[Music]
like
a noun and verbs are the ones that you
should know and then anything else i'm
like yeah
yeah
proverb
i
i don't know what that is i mean i know
i know that it exists but if you i don't
exist
right i should know this is my language
tell me how to use a semicolon
[Laughter]
using a comma and a full stop at the
same time
kind of sentence you actually know the
way that i think i learned how to use
semicolon yeah it's a the lonely island
song semicolon
i remember that yeah
i was like oh that actually that's the
first time i've seen the explanation of
semicolon yeah i'm like that makes sense
now that makes sense yeah i don't know i
just feel like with the era of like
water corrects and [ __ ] like that we
just pay way less attention to it like
i've just started using apostrophes in
places where apostrophes don't need to
be used but like it just looks right and
i i know it's wrong sometimes well it's
like with uh languages like japanese
sometimes that some people some of the
younger generation don't know how to
write the kanji because they're typing
it all the time yeah
and that's like a thing yeah
is that true joey yes absolutely i'm
using other countries and characters as
well that's like a big problem yeah yeah
because i like when i was in school i
you know i took like the kanji
proficiency test so obviously i was like
just used to writing it all yeah but
once i got that degree i was like all
right cool never have to write this [ __ ]
ever again and now when i look at it or
now when someone's like how do you write
this i just kind of stop and i'm like
i should know this
i can read it
but i can't write it yeah and there's so
many symbols like that yeah you've done
language learning streams as well
uh japanese as well hasn't it how's that
been going i can't really do them as
much anymore because of like certain
permissions issues but i'm thinking of
getting back into it with just uh you
know making a list of vocabulary
beforehand and running through flash
cards with with chat because i feel like
um
that can be entertaining in its own way
i think somehow it always becomes a fun
time even ideas that i think are going
to be kind of boring yeah it ends up
being fun you know what's amazed me
about streaming no matter what obscure
thing i do just one goddamn expert
appears out of nowhere in the chat one
goddamn like you know i'll be doing like
sudoku and the world 2017 world sudoku
champion will come in my chat and be
like hey what are you doing this
technical you know what i mean like no
matter what i do somehow an expert comes
out of nowhere yeah what is this like
[ __ ] reddit yeah yeah
it's insane i'll be like
do like a water grading stream and like
the guy who designed water will appear
in my chat hi i discovered water
hello
kind of in the same veins sometimes
there will be like um there will be like
a movie or a song that i know for a fact
only like 10 000 people have heard or
listened to and someone in chat knows
about it oh i remember that wait do you
and they do yeah i'm the producer
i mean of course like that very obscure
childhood memory that you have of a game
or a show and then you describe it and
then chat is like oh yeah i know what
that is of course i know what that is
i'm like wild how do you how do you know
that
what's wrong with you guys
i just know i mean chat is a curse but
also like an almighty being that just
knows everything it's pretty impressive
it is oh it's like a conglomerate yeah
right
it's it's weird like see seeing seeing
people refer to chat it's like yes it's
i don't know such a weird concept to me
because you know everyone in chat is an
individual person but then chat just
becomes just melds into this one
entity
yeah one all-knowing entity that is uh
equally single brain cells
it's like being part of hololive um of
course you are
you stream on youtube but what do you
think about the whole twitch streaming
as well have you ever been interested in
streaming on twitch and what kind of
differences do you think that would make
if you ever did
it's pretty unexplored territory to be
honest so i haven't really thought too
much about it um i feel like you know i
have watched a couple streamers on
twitch but for whatever reason i just
feel like i gravitate more towards
youtube i know that they both have their
pros and cons for sure but i've gotten
so comfortable on youtube and one thing
that i really love about it uh on
youtube especially is that uh archives
are kept forever
you know yeah my streams become videos
that people can just watch whenever they
want and that's true check out the whole
backlog you know i really love that but
um i do think that for example twitch's
uh sub feature is superior that is
certain but um i think they both have
you know their pros and cons i just feel
like at this point it's like a comfort
thing i'm just so used to youtube now
and and the way that people you know
interact with each other in chat there
there are so many layers to it that i
just kind of prefer yeah i find it
really curious or really weird to see
like both these platforms just having
different cultures around them and it's
almost like a different etiquette where
like when you're on a twitch twitch
stream just it feels completely
different to watching a youtube stream
yeah and i'm not sure like i'm not sure
if it's just the community or if it's
just like emotes or what it is but yeah
both both platforms to me feel oddly
different whenever i'm watching a
different creator stream on that
platform
there's like a culture to it for sure i
have noticed because i i watch uh
streamers who stream on both and it is
quite different i gotta say
that's not me that's not me being like
that's not i'm not throwing any shade at
twitch i'm just i'm just saying that
i mean it's not paying you it's not for
me um but
i mean at the same time it's just what
you prefer at the end of the day
everyone's got their preference and uh
just choose what you like and that's how
it goes like yeah like i i don't think
i'd have a difficult time streaming on
youtube now that i'm just so used to
streaming on twitch yeah yeah and the
vibe is different
is totally different people are
way more joking on twitch i think people
are used to people are monkeys on twitch
we got a couple monkeys on youtube oh
that's true but but it is a kind of
different feeling for sure um at the end
of the day though i will go to where the
creator i like is that is the truth for
me personally but that's not always the
case for everyone you know everyone's
kind of different yeah some people are
lazy to like open another tab i don't
get it i get it i mean i mean
clicking a link to go on another
platform get out of here
get up no i mean like my poor thingy
can't handle it no because like i mean i
mean there's just so many platforms
nowadays and so many different apps and
stuff that sometimes you just talked
about yeah i mean something absolutely i
can't handle all the tabs
sometimes you just build up a uh like
schedule the right word no it's a
pattern you build up a pattern about
what time you spend on each app right so
like i've been watching a lot of youtube
shorts nowadays even though i could go
and t and even though they're just
recycled tick tocks right but it's just
it's just because i'm as a youtuber i'm
just on youtube more that it's just more
convenient for me and so i don't like if
you watch a lot of twitch streamers then
sure it's easy to watch more twitch
streamers but if you're not like
integrated into that kind of ecosystem
it's like it's it's weird it's because
like it feels like you're going more out
of your way just to view this one
creator as opposed to just being on the
platform naturally you know so i i do
think it is a factor that matters which
is why you see
a lot of people who are just famous on
one platform nowadays you can have
people who are famous on youtube and
just not have a presence anywhere else
and you you know and i feel like i feel
like the super super successful content
creators are people who can like break
out of that just one platform and be
able to like have a presence on multiple
platforms right i mean i am a person who
kind of feels like consistency is is a
big key but some people are so big that
it doesn't matter you know it doesn't
matter where you go people will follow
kind of thing you know um but i do i do
kind of see like the uh the merit and
having all your stuff in one place it's
also just personally what i prefer
because of how my brain works you know i
like to have everything in one place
because i'm already a really big scatter
brain in the first place if i had stuff
all over the place i'd lose my mind so i
kind of you're juggling enough things as
it is honestly there's a lot going on
so i'm just scared to have everything on
one platform right like yeah you know
i'm that mentality of like just put
don't put all your eggs in one basket
kind of thing i do think that however
music is like the one thing that is like
yeah easily able to hold it tired oh
yeah yeah
it's like i mean that's why every
youtuber on earth tries to become a pop
star or yeah yeah because varying levels
because because that's where you know
money is good uh longevity is good you
can you can have time to work on it
music is definitely also it doesn't
matter how old you get right you can
still keep yeah you can as long as it
sounds good
on youtube you know you turn 30
bye-bye sorry guys you're um
[Laughter]
why was his reaction so soon i mean 30
years old man
yeah i'm having i'm having trouble
hearing already
it's not really just trying to age gate
old people
we are joking we are friends we're going
to make these jokes all right it's like
you have to clarify that you're
bantering these days calm down a little
bit
is it the same is the same on uh
hollow live with the with the friends
these people get upset when you mock
each other you know i will say um we
like to we like to banter quite a bit um
but we gotta remind y'all again and we
really don't have to but i'm going to
anyway we are all really good friends
yeah exactly
and so
at the same time you know a lot of us
have kind of i mean i know i certainly
came up in friend groups where we would
we would you know
throw [ __ ] at each other and it was all
in good fun we never really kind of step
over the line it's it's all stuff that
we're comfortable with and it's just
it's just good fun no no one hates
anyone just you know sometimes you gotta
calm down take a step back um we know
each other pretty well and um
it's just like that sometimes we're
having fun there's really just like some
people though that just don't get that
whole like bantering or like you know
when is it over the line or like you
know there are people like over analyze
conversations on streams and youtube
videos where it's like this is the frame
this is the very frame where their
friendships started to crumble ever have
you seen them streaming since then don't
think so not friends anymore it's like
no dude it's like it's fine yeah i feel
like like even more so with like the v
tubing community because um
do you ever feel like a lot of people
like really really analyze
what you like what your behaviors are
yeah like maybe a bit too much sometimes
yeah i'd say so i've seen several
paragraphs analyzing my personality from
my deepest insecurities to things that
uh everyone already knows etc i've seen
plenty of things like that um
and you know it's just it's gonna happen
it's gonna happen when so much of
yourself is put out there you know
that's just how it's gonna be but uh i
will say
um it is the truth we really do only
give a percentage of ourselves uh when
we stream even though it may be so many
hours in a day um there's still a whole
side where we go off and live lives i'm
still you know occasionally reaping the
occasional soul don't tell that sensei
about that but you know i'm i'm doing
other stuff as well and it's important
to remember that it's important to like
take a deep breath and realize that you
know we've all got lives so where does
music fit into your career like
how do you find time for that where do
you find time for that uh i mean i think
that the only
only thing i can say is it's just it's
the one thing that i love doing so
completely and utterly that time just
isn't a factor to me energy isn't a
factor to me all of that just disappears
in me wanting to create music and i
don't compromise anything for it i
believe that's called a passion
that sounds like a passion that sounds
like a passion to me so no matter what i
will find a way to fit it in even if
other things have to kind of you know
take a back seat um even things like
streaming etc which will not make
everyone happy but you get over it you
know you get over it at the end of the
day it's what i love prioritize what you
want to do right exactly yeah exactly
why else am i here you know
and not make me think that exactly i
mean if that was the case then i'd quit
and yeah um i mean if if you want me to
to stay here i'm gonna do what i want to
do yeah that's all i can say this
episode is sponsored by zen markets
gentlemen you know what sometimes can be
a little bit tricky what buying items in
japan for the sponsor of today's episode
zen market makes being an anime fan so
much easier wanna get your hands on some
of that exclusive anime merchandise only
available in japan i do connor in fact i
recently bought a jojo stone mask that
you see in the part one anime i bought
it exclusively at the jojo exhibit that
is only held here in japan and look at
this rui mousepad did you bring that
here i i did i have the hina one at home
which is the better one so if you want
to get the heater mouse pad then you can
buy that from zen market too for a flat
fee of only 300 yen per item zenmarket
gives you access to all the items we
mentioned and so much more even though
we live in japan even for us the
language barrier can make things
difficult joey shut the [ __ ] up well
fred no more because zen market's
impeccable customer support team
provides native customer support in over
14 languages
and on top of that they offer a wide
range of payment options including
paypal and even cryptocurrency we live
in a society so no more waiting around
for the day you'll finally be able to
visit japan go over to our very own
trash taste landing page link in
description below and check out some of
the amazing japanese exclusive merch zen
market ships directly to your doorstep
back to the episode do you find it hard
to like bring
that energy to your stream even though
like you your schedule is obviously so
busy
there must be some streams where you're
like
guys i'm like today i'm just done
honestly like i can't do it today that's
another thing that i have kind of had to
start learning is management of energy
because even if you want to stream all
the time every day you know to see chat
to make them happy et cetera the end at
the end of the day um i only have so
much energy and chat's not gonna have
fun because they can tell when i'm low
energy like i said i've seen paragraphs
analyzing every single facet of my
personality they can tell when you're
low energy that's the truth so sometimes
it's worth it to you know give yourself
a little more breathing room
occasionally though i get a little ahead
of myself schedule too many streams uh
it'd be like that and it's taking quite
a toll on my energy in that after i'm
done streaming i just go lay down and
that's the only thing i do besides
streaming and making music is sleeping
so how much sleep do you get for a day
six hours a night which is not terrible
but it's not
a little bit more yeah yeah
yeah so i'm trying to work on that a
little bit um but there's just a lot to
do and there's a lot you have to put
your energy into and um when it comes to
music one thing that i've noticed is
that it takes a little less energy for
me simply because there's no pressure
about making mistakes on stream you know
in your work process nobody really sees
all the awful mistakes that you make
when you're recording 100 takes over and
over again you put it together and the
song that you've made is hopefully if
you've done it right the best possible
thing that you could have made it be
right with streaming it's just go be
good at improv be good at games be good
at something be perfect for the next two
hours exactly and just pray and that
takes a lot of energy out of you you
know there's a lot of stress that comes
with that um that maybe you can be
really good at hiding maybe you're not
so good at hiding it um it just it just
depends man and it's rough it's uh i
feel like you've got to learn it along
the way as well because no one's ever
prepared to be like okay i'm going to
stream even though like i'm like low
energy and sometimes you have to like
just force it out of you and it's just
it's so difficult because that's why i
don't stream so often as well because i
also have like a certain amount of
energy and if it's like below that then
it's just not going to be a good stream
i think that a lot of the time though
when you feel rough or you don't feel
like you've got the energy for a stream
yeah often when you actually start and
get into it you kind of get into the
rhythm of it and you kind of get a lot
more energy it also depends on what
you're doing there are some there are
some streams that you're just like i'm
having a good time playing this or i'm
having a good time doing this activity
and there's some streams where you're
just like this isn't an okay time and i
have to make it seem like it's a lot
more fun than just an okay time
i mean i do gotta admit i think i barely
scraped by in terms of the personality
you need to stream because not everyone
can stream you have to have a certain
kind of personality i don't know if you
guys know this but i've seen
a couple quote unquote
reliable scientific research papers or
whatever somebody said something on the
internet and i took it as fact but this
is i believe it
that's a big quotation
i can understand this being true so you
know i'm not saying this is a fact but i
don't think the human
brain was meant to deal with
10 000 or so people watching you all 100
we weren't built for it now technically
i'm not a human but listen
i have a human body so we're we're going
throughout the research paper exactly
but we really aren't meant to so you
have to have a certain kind of
personality to not mentally collapse
what is that personality you have to
have a little bit of an ego you have to
have a smidge it just needs to be a
little bit it needs to be enough
you know because
not everyone can do it that's just the
truth you have to have a certain kind of
personality you can't brute force it and
that's fine that is absolutely okay but
it's just kind of how it is you can
build it up yourself but yeah it is a
prerequisite
do you see yourself doing the streaming
for a much longer time or do you think
there's like a certain amount of time
where you're just like yeah i'm probably
going to try something different after a
certain amount of time right like a time
limit on this um it does take more
energy for me than some other folks i
think and with that being said i think
that i'd like to try it out and continue
on for a longer time however the
frequency with which i do it may change
at some point because yeah i mean uh
yeah i'll be thoroughly impressed if you
can keep this up for the next year
have you heard about this thing it's
called a it's called weekends it's uh
it's it's where most people like uh
holidays as well
holiday i've heard of that before
yeah but in a sense these days i kind of
find myself sitting down after a stream
being like all right break time watch
something on netflix and um i think to
myself
i want to do something work related and
that's when you know you've become a
workaholic and you've got the illness so
it's good but i i often found the
struggle where
i would sometimes
invest too heavily in work and then i
would think oh i just haven't hung out
with anyone in a long time
and i feel kind of lonely and but but
then i but then i i've spent too much
time working and i can't hang out with
people because they're hanging out with
people who are more consistent they're
hanging out which is totally fair
what do you mean well because if you're
if you're often not available people
don't invite you to things right so if
you if everyone knows that you're not
going to turn up to stuff most of the
time people stop inviting you
so you kind of have to balance very
carefully and like going to stuff but
also wanting to be there for work
because i also feel the same way with
streaming where i'm like i'm not there
enough i'm not participating in the
ecosystem enough you know so it's a
struggle do you ever have that problem
all the time yeah but i mean recently
i've been
i've been trying to fix that by instead
reaching out to people that i haven't
talked to because that's yeah that's my
work around it's like yeah because like
people have if i get to the point where
people stop inviting me because i get
too busy yeah give your brain
i make my i'll make my own effects
i'll be like i'll be like i don't
now i'm like all i want to do is work
but i'll schedule something in in like
two weeks because i'm like i'm it's not
right now it's not right now it's not
work right now but it comes around i'm
like [ __ ] i want to work but i'm like
i'm glad i scheduled that because now i
can actually force myself to go and have
a good time and not think about doing
work i feel like moving has helped you
as well because i remember before you
never invite people to your place at all
because
because it's a mess yeah it was a mess
well pewdiepie roasted me
terrible yeah but now you're in a more
central place so it's easier to just
like invite people and sort out your own
because you know when i lived like an
hour away at like a minimum of an hour
journey right
an hour is a long time to lose in a day
when i try and make every goddamn hour
count yeah so when two hours because
they're back right you know now it's a
lot quicker for me which is great for
most places um but yeah i would spend so
much time traveling and i can't i'm not
the kind of person who can work on a
train i don't know about you well no you
can't definitely definitely not tokyo
trains yeah you know if i'm standing
there's absolutely no way i can do any
work yeah sometimes i cannot figure it
out away dude do you get this thing
those houses how what work do you do on
a train well i can answer emails i can
work on scripts because you can do it
okay [ __ ] off can you work on scripts on
the train journey
do you ever okay do you ever have right
i don't know if this is another thing or
this is just a me thing right i have
these things right it's an email but
it's an email that i need to sit down
and look at yeah it's a focus email yeah
yeah i can't do it when i'm standing i
gotta sit down and be like
okay
hundred percent yeah i don't have that i
don't know i'm envious i i i have that
like i can't answer important emails on
my phone i need to like sit down on a
laptop or a computer i'm so much nicer
yeah you don't have the big screen so i
can think about my words on a bigger
resolution i don't know why that matters
do you activate different neurons when
you sit down like i think back me up
here do you do that i agree actually
entirely especially when it comes to
music um though sometimes i'll be like
i'll be like on a plane on a train i get
my phone out i'm like i'm ready to work
and i'm like nope time for a nap and i
just put my phone away people who work
on planes are like just like what
happened in their childhood i don't know
i can't i could work on planes what
happened in your childhood i can work on
playing [ __ ] up it's working on a
plane is different than working on a
train okay
with with a train
you're like doing this in the [ __ ]
cabin there's people next to you like
they bring the food over you're like oh
[ __ ]
because because because on a plane you
are you're on my phone no no no no no
you don't work on your phone joey
you need a [ __ ] laptop or at least a
tablet a phone
you can't pretty much
no i mean what happens is i think i'm
going to so three
levels i put it on the table and i'm
ready to work and then suddenly um
someone comes with a glass of chardonnay
they're like here you go i'm like all
right well i gotta find a freaking place
for this
thing and i'm looking at the map and i
wonder what movies they have yeah yeah
suddenly i'm looking at the movies holy
[ __ ] they have this one i want to see if
if i was in like first class of business
i had the whole [ __ ] thing set up
yeah okay maybe we can talk about
working what i'm an economy i don't i'm
just depressed i don't want to think
about work i want to watch whatever
jason statham
no i'm depressed because you know
there's no good movies on it's always
it's always [ __ ] movies which i hate
yeah it's playing movies so if if i'm
going to be in a bad mood i might as
well be in a bad mood and do some work
that's that's that's mine that's exactly
like that's why like i hate like
watching movies on a plane because for
one they're all movies i don't want to
watch i'm like well what is there to do
i'm not just going to like [ __ ]
blankly stare out the window yeah yeah
exactly take a nap i don't know yeah i
just sleep no okay when i say one i
can't sleep yeah when i say i work on a
plane i'm not working yeah the whole
[ __ ] trip yeah jerry's like making
calls sell my stuff god damn it i
haven't seen my kids in three days
no okay if i'm like flying from tokyo to
l.a right it's like what 10 11 hour
flight
i'm probably working max like three or
four hours yeah same the rest of the
time the rest of the time i'm like
reading a book or like taking a nap or
watching a movie god forbid yeah like
doing something else basically like i'm
not that much of a [ __ ] machine where
i'm like 11 hours on this flight all
right 11 full hours of work like
mudan is the only guy yeah
the final stage he brings his desktop on
the plane
no not the type of guy who's like oh you
need a video editor let me whip out my
phone real quick
oh my god he's done that yeah right yeah
he's done that before
he's he's used the
remote control on his phone to edit
on his pc yeah
that's what i'm saying this guy's
plugged into the matrix this is it this
is when you reach your final form yeah
this is
this is the final evolution of like
humans you know
but like how do you script on your phone
like especially if you're standing up
right in a crowded trade it's just it's
impossible for me to get the right
mindset let alone i can't get like a
single thought together so if i'm in
like a crowded train i'm not writing
script i'm like doing like the research
for the script because it's easy enough
to just you know because you're already
on your phone on a crowded train right
like looking at twitter or whatever so
what's the difference between looking at
twitter and looking at like a web page
or you know or like an anime user
philip defranco i'm just like yeah well
like a youtube video right like it's
it's the same motion but like i'm not
there [ __ ] typing it out on a crowded
train obviously not like if i'm sitting
down on the train sure i can [ __ ]
whip it out and start typing some [ __ ]
in but
i don't know i wish i had that power man
i mean if you did that you'd probably be
able to upload every week
maybe that's what's missing
do you find like you have to be in a
certain environment when you write your
music or is it just like whenever
inspiration hits that's a good question
to be completely honest i can't force it
i just can't sometimes i'm in the mood
to write this song sometimes i'm not and
if i force it then the lyrics are gonna
turn out real bad so
um i just have to be really mindful of
when i'm feeling that inspiration though
it does happen to
it does get a bit stronger as the
deadline creeps up it's not
procrastination i promise it's just
that's what they all say
i feel that making music is a completely
different part of your brain that is
doesn't overlap with any other type of
activity definitely yeah like i couldn't
write music on a plane or anywhere
that's not my room or and even when i'm
in my room i need to be as as kelly said
i need to be in like a specific mood
that's me in scripting like i need to be
in like a specific i could do like admin
stuff on my phone and [ __ ] like that but
like scripting is like sacred that's
probably why your scripting is way
better than mine it sounds like you have
that with everything though gone sounds
like you have to be in the mood to [ __ ]
as well i mean there's nothing wrong
with being in the mood to [ __ ]
this man ever everything needs to be in
a monk like zen mode to get everything
done
we're like god can you order some food
now it's not the time i need to be in
the right mindset
i just get distracted too easily you do
[Music]
genius takes a while yeah
if you stop like if you actually open
the [ __ ] app yeah
that's what i need like the certain apps
that i'm comfortable with i want to stay
on those apps don't don't give me
anything new tick-tock scares me okay
yes i'm a boomer okay
say it say it no no no okay you're gonna
age way better than me
i'm just jealous
he has the upper hand now how does it
feel looking at chris and being like i'm
going to be that in five years
that's brutal too
oh my god
we all know it's true though kind of
almost true
just looks good
yeah i'll be bored at chris's age oh my
god
sad but true sounds for true prayer for
me oh my god what's your what's your
favorite uh
like live streaming meme
or like words that they use because
livestream has its own lingo that's
right let me think
let me think
i don't think i've ever seen cali throw
out like the kw or like i can't pog or
anything yeah you don't kick w you don't
sam yeah that's because she's not on
twitch
are you able to say the word pog or kick
w without no i can't
you can't you can't give out like a monk
i know i'm pretty cringe here and there
but that's just a little it's a little
too much i think i might i might
collapse into myself like a black hole
i can't do it man
so that's all you're gonna get from me
because somebody's been sending me pepe
hands
recently and um
yeah
it stays in my mind um is there a meme
you like to see papa ah let's see
um
let me think let me think
i have to think really carefully about
how i answer this one because every
conversation every question you ask is
mean i do want to know what people's
tastes and memes are so i can kind of
gauge that level of interest we don't do
a lot of we don't do a lot of memes in
my chat i feel like you know there's
youtubers versus twitch streamers right
yeah it's kind of it's it's hard because
i feel like it depends on the chat right
yeah i'm certainly not like
for example it's not that everyone in
holo ian's chats are like averse to
memes no no it's just the crowd that
i've attracted i think isn't super
hardcore and we still we still have a
few yeah sometimes i'll go to a v tubers
stream and i'll watch it and i'll just
like not understand it and they'll be
like oh my god they said banana it's the
thing it's the thing of the year joke
and i'm like what
no no it doesn't i don't know what
twitch at least i think i feel like i
haven't seen that i felt i felt that
applies to me and twitch honestly
no some of the dean jokes yeah the in
jokes yeah yeah just because i don't
spend enough time watching twitch
streams i don't know maybe yeah maybe
i'm just talking about i feel like
yeah i feel that with twitch is like
multiple layers it's like it starts off
with a twitch reference that is specific
to twitch and then that evolves into an
intro so it's like multiple layers that
you have to understand whereas on
youtube there isn't really like specific
lingo i guess i don't know with hololive
it's i think all the memes that come
from the subreddit i assume right yeah
that's right there are a lot of things
popping off there i think for sure but i
mean it's the same with trash days right
like all of the things come from
that's true that is true from somewhere
that's for sure but i mean that's what
we need reddit for just just the memes
yeah we keep up to date yeah just keep
up to date with all the memes right
i mean i guess i guess occasionally when
i it's just little things it's not
necessarily just words being spammed in
chat but rather rather things that i do
or make a habit of for example uh my
intro and outro a lot of times when i
start the stream uh i'll turn up the
reverb and the echo and i'll just say
and then everyone in the chat just says
go or they they use the emote
that's about it hi callie how are you
hey that's it that's about it and then
at the end everyone says peace turn up
the reverb turn up the echo piece and
everyone spams peace in the chat you
know but it's not it's not just like
word after word that's the same kind of
thing not a lot of you know emotes of
course you know you pull out the glow
sticks and the music emote for them for
the live show
that's about the extent of where it goes
to i think now for others in en i can
see it being kind of different you know
they've all got their own personal like
inside jokes and words people like to
say in chat but
people get people get frustrated about
that sometimes because not everybody's a
big fan of the
the the same memes being used over and
over again there's a lot of fighting
yeah it also makes it difficult
sometimes for newer people to come in if
it's just all in jokes right yeah it's
important to maintain the balance of a
chat shut the [ __ ] up
because you also don't want to be that
guy that's like um what does this mean
chad you know like
yeah there's that pressure as well so
yeah exactly i guess the closest thing
we ever got was
um
you guys know um adam sandler yeah of
course
[Laughter]
yeah musical artist that would never
hurt us let me go do you guys know this
guy called uh nicholas cage
um do you know barack obama
so where is this going
i mean he just he just has become like a
prominent figure in like the lore same
with the shrek it's just
it's stuff like this
new people getting into the stream would
maybe get confused so how is adam
sandler playing a part um
he's just always kind of been there like
his spirit it's like hard what you know
long time ago there was an event where
that we all we all it's we cannonically
we erased it from our brains and i've
been having trouble
remembering it right um and um there was
the existence of of an emote i believe i
can't remember what it looks like and i
don't remember what we called it but i
know old adam was involved and we
banished it uh from the chat we had like
a burning ceremony and everything um
is this like your mandela effect in
motion or something like that
we get a little crazy stuff so i
understand i'm missing so many like
parts of the context of this story we've
jumped right to the exile
how did we get to the exile how do they
even begin i mean i was just kind of
like listen when when i was young baby
reaper um mama mori often put ol adam on
the screen um when she went off to work
and i'd watch ol adam back then just me
just me just just get out of here
and of course it came up again in chat
people were like oh what movies do you
like and i was like you guys seen a
happy gilmore and they're like i love
happy young laws
actually i do think that that's what
what are your favorite adam sandler
movies mr deeds i love mr dudes
my favorite scene is like hitting his
foot yeah and his foot's like black from
the uh the frostbite yeah
that's right i heard my first curse
words from that movie i don't remember
that i've seen the movie
i've seen i think 50 first dates that's
actually like a good one yeah i think
that's a good one and uh
click's my favorite that's a pretty good
one too management oh sydney showed me
wedding singer the other day because i
was talking about adam sandler yeah what
were you
right now i mean uh what was i gonna say
a good old girl adam he's just he's
become like a presence and it's it's
hard to explain why but but he just he
just creeped in have you guys seen uncut
gems it's amazing i haven't i've been
trying to get these guys to watch it
it's such a good movie i remember you
talking about it he's so good it's like
he's actually acting like
he's actually trying exactly my movie
list is like my to watch anime animated
watch list which is like yeah i'll watch
it someday and then um they're all
movies i've heard of but like yeah i'll
get to it eventually i'll watch it it's
good yeah well what gets me now is like
sometimes memes just get me want to uh
just get me like the urge to watch
certain movies now like megamind memes
have been like coming up more recently
and i'm just like i should watch that
movie i have not watched it's
yeah and just seeing the memes like i
saw the memes and i'm just like let me
watch a few clips and i'm like oh this
is maybe i should like sit down and
watch this maybe i'll do that tonight
actually no i'm thinking about watching
i'll watch megamind do you also have to
be in the right mindset to watch that
it's actually mind gone
it does it's a kids movie you don't have
to be in a mindset
is it pixelated
like dreamworks and that kind of stuff
that's supposed to be the type of genre
that does so well because you can watch
it yeah that's right but like sometimes
you know when you watch like a show or
something that people have been talking
about you and you just watch it mega
mine's just not just to keep up with
playing masterpiece you don't need to
pay attention you just watch it
i want to pay attention to the [ __ ] i
watch connor
i i want to pay attention to it there's
something there's a genre of
entertainment that does very well
because you don't need to pay attention
it's the brain dead entertainment brain
dead yeah i don't i i even in the brain
dead stuff i like to pay attention just
because when you're making thumbnails
yeah exactly stuff like that something
you can i thought that was what youtube
videos for i thought that was was what
trash taste was for you know that's
that's the brain dead content right
if you've got subtitles though it's kind
of a little harder the trash tastes
youtube's
because like sometimes sometimes you put
on a youtube video right sometimes you
put it on like the second monitor and
then it starts and you're like oh oh oh
this is some main monitor [ __ ] oh oh
okay
yeah you have to like swap it over to
the main monitor you're like oh okay
this is this is
that's that's how you know it's top tier
content but it's not on your second
monitor it's on your main monitor man i
get that i get that
that to me is just like every movie i
can't have a movie on in the background
right now i can't do that either i could
do that yeah i know you can can you do
that
ah you know it's tough these days
because i actually don't really consume
a lot of media sadly enough because
you're streaming nine hours a day every
day and i have this i have an issue
where if i really get into a series i
have to finish it in one go like um
i was reading a manga that i got into
the other night it's been out for a long
time
it a manga
manga did i really say it like you smell
like that
i can't believe it i'll never forgive
myself
i just love how we all like all three of
us
it's like
it's actually kind of it's not a super
new one it's called what was it um i
believe in japanese
oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah i read it
yeah i watched the netflix show i
watched all of it and i was like this is
pretty good and so i just had to figure
out what the ending was and so i read
the whole manga from start to finish in
one day and i was like i could have done
a lot of other stuff but i had to keep
reading it was it worth it yeah it was
good i liked it um i thought the ending
was okay it was fine um but i thought
like the writing and like the the
emotional like writing was it gets a
little much sometimes like a little edgy
but overall i thought it was very well
done so i recommend it i think that's
just like most survival hormones yeah
it's just like it's just like a little
touch of too edgy by the way this is not
because of swede game that i've been
getting into like kaiji and stuff like
that i liked kaiji and and you liked
kaiju before it was cool
but like i've been into like death game
stuff like before squid gameplay
that's a form of inspiration
yeah i don't know to me squid not squid
game just death game manga and anime are
definitely definitely like something
like guilty pleasures oh yeah because
there are some i think in terms of like
the tier of like well-written death
games i think squid game is like on the
better on the side with like the better
written ones even though it is a bit
edgy sometimes but sometimes you just
like read something that's just pure
edge and it just for some reason it's
just
i don't know man it's like junk food for
me i can name about ten yeah
a lot of them do feel quite samey after
a while though yeah okay you start to be
able to predict things the way the games
are going to go it's because they're all
influenced by each other yeah so it's
like there's only so much you can do
until someone is like no let me try
something else yeah have you watched
squid game then yeah i have i did i
watched it again all in one night
because i couldn't take a break youtube
yeah and i thought it was very good i
thought it was a very solid show and i
liked it a lot of course there are
things that i wasn't
super into but overall i liked it i
thought it was good yeah it definitely
wasn't the perfect show but really good
yeah whatever what i find interesting
about the whole squid game like getting
mainstream stuff now is i've seen so
many debates about the subs versus dub
in in the mainstream now
and it's so surreal right i mean some of
the the dubbing and script game was i
keep getting recommending clips of some
of the dub clips and squid game and i'm
just like how are people watching this
right now because i think i think i
can't remember i think i saw it on like
philip defranco where he there was a
metric of how many people watched it
dubbed i think it was like 60 or like 69
people more people watch the dogs
because people people just on netflix
people just
when you when you do it if you've got
your language sent to english it's just
automatically linked yeah so a lot of
people don't want to then flip i think
as well for some countries like the the
original korean uh like voices just
weren't available what yeah because like
i remember my sister was telling me uh
in australia there was no option other
than the english dub what like you have
to watch it in the english style and
she's like what the [ __ ] i don't want to
watch it in english but yeah so i think
it also depends on the the country as
well i mean which is a bit weird it's
interesting because i actually i've
watched netflix shows with the dub when
they aren't originally like when it's a
different language other than english
i've watched english english dubs on
netflix that i didn't think were
terrible but that
that was something special
like half the actors are speaking in a
different like type of english yeah like
i think half the voice actors are
americans then the other half like
british the old woman just doesn't sound
like an old woman you know that should
be like the first thing that you you try
and do to like at least give a little
bit of effort to not sound like a 25
year old yeah from the clips i've seen
it definitely gives you the impression
that none of the dub voice actors knew
how big this was going to be i don't
have anyone involved and i don't think
even netflix knew how this how big this
was going to be um and you can
definitely see it
apparent yeah because like yeah i don't
know
maybe it's just because we're in the
anime community but for me especially
when it comes to live action i can't
imagine watching live action in anything
but the original language it's so much
more jarring it's so jarring
although it is also a guilty pleasure of
mine like every now and then i watch
like a live-action hollywood film with
the japanese dub it's oh my god it's why
joey why so funny it is fun
and even when they get like top voice
actors in like the anime sphere to like
voice over like vin diesel and [ __ ]
fast and furious i'm just like
it's so weird it's so weird to hear a
different voice that's not vin diesel's
coming out in diesel's mouth yeah yeah
it's very funny my curiosity i mean
luckily you should it's really funny
luckily in japan normally all the movies
are in subbed in the cinema yeah yeah
yeah thank you because i can watch them
it's all the ones that make it the dvd
that are not yeah dvd they have an
option yeah yeah thank god thank god
thank you japan and yeah i can actually
enjoy going to the cinema it is weird
watching like japanese dubs of like uh
western cartoons though that is weird
like oh like simpsons yeah simpsons like
hearing it's japanese rick and morty as
well that was that was
so surreal but it's so weird that's when
i can like kind of get behind it because
it's it's it's it actually suits it a
lot in a lot of the scenes like they
they like whoever voices rick [ __ ]
blew it out of the park yeah
i want to go listen to this now it's not
bad
okay okay this is like the
being on the other side of things where
it's like oh no not all dubs are bad
even if it's like originally in english
foreign is better than russian everyone
knows
of course
[Music]
yeah conor in russian trash tastes like
he's like he sounds like he wrestles
bears for a living
i really really am envious of that man
so have you had like time to watch
anything else in your schedule or is it
just like just random stuff random stuff
um recently i've been i got really into
like um it's a super obscure uh like
yakuza film series called um
i know what it's called in english um
battles without honor and or humanity
i need to figure out what the name
sounds like that is that is the most
google translated title i've ever heard
find out the name of it i wish i could
look it up so what's the plot of these
movies um it's a really long plot
it's just about this one this one guy
and his entire experience from start to
finish uh entering the the yakuza family
and it's it's just i can't explain why i
like it it's just kind of cool and like
a lot of the sound clips are just really
iconic the music is really iconic you'll
hear it sampled a lot in japanese rap
it's just really neat and there's a lot
of blood um it was one of the like most
prominent i think yakuza films made in
japan there's five of them i haven't
watched the last one but i've been
slowly working through them i found them
on amazon with english subtitles there
was only one copy in the world and i got
it
oh wow so it wasn't even streamed it was
like physical media holy [ __ ] that's how
you know that's how you know it's like
underground oh gee yeah i was just i was
recommending how did you find it i was
recommended it by a friend who really
likes japanese movies and i was like
ah i should give this i should check it
out um and i really i really like when
was the last time you bought physical
media
mother knows breasts oh yeah you're
you're zzz like i bought it to watch it
yeah i'm watching it
you've watched you've you've actually
put it in you put it in all right i
don't have a dvd player yeah that's what
i thought
no but uh playstation works just fine
interestingly yeah i can't remember the
last time i've i brought like a dvd or a
blu-ray that i actually watched yeah
right i've brought i've even bought like
anime blu-rays
and dvds but just like that's just so i
can own them physically even if i bought
it i'm putting that [ __ ] in you know how
annoying it is getting out going bending
down putting it in [ __ ] do you mention i
can just chromecast
knees yeah i'm an old man now you know
oh sorry i'm a child now but i was an
old man one time and that that was very
difficult too you're an old man stuck in
a childhood man
i i don't i just want to do everything
digitally it's so much easier oh yeah
i mean i mean that's why it's become
that's that's why you smell like dying
medium yeah that's that's why you like
i mean
forget dvds you don't watch anything
that's not on netflix now you know what
you know what sucks is that uh you know
everything good is on like hulu and hbo
and i'm like we don't have that [ __ ] how
do we how do i it's so unfair i'm like i
don't know how to do this please help me
i want hbo everything seems to be on hbo
i mean all a lot of the good shows a lot
i say i say like a lot of the critically
acclaimed shows seem to be on hbo yeah
and you can't get it outside of america
is this where you can live in a
sponsorship perhaps actually
a funny thing like a lot of a lot of hbo
shows and a lot of tv shows are
available on youtube to buy right but
i've i've noticed like because
yeah yeah because i've watched schnobl
uh and i watched that on youtube oh i
watched on amazon prime oh is that it's
on amazon prime here yeah what's your
name okay but that's probably like the
last amazing live action tv show that
i've like probably got into yeah i love
that yeah [ __ ] amazing
wow you guys just realize sometimes how
things have developed with like anime
and japanese culture in general because
i remember a time when i was younger and
i had to beg mama mori to drive me 40
minutes to the only small anime store
in our state i mean the fact that you
even had an anime story yeah yeah you'll
probably just show it
listen that pocky was six dollars and i
remember saving up all what little
allowance i could say
oh my god
i think you pay that with a romney
i don't want gaunt but like i came into
anime just as it was kind of becoming
more globalized the internet was kind of
kicking into full force
uh and yeah even back then it was like
you couldn't get anything like nothing
yeah you didn't live through the dog no
all i could get was like the worst i had
to deal with was like yugioh gx espanol
part one that was like yeah yeah that
was like the worst i had to deal with
but i could still get it like i could
get it
no i mean
we could also get it as well it just was
a lot harder to find you know it's we
had to put more work into it other than
just streaming i feel like streaming
made anime just like kind of kind of
like it made anime [ __ ] way more
accessible because even back in my day
i still bought dvds whenever i could
right but then once streaming became a
thing i just stopped buying dvds at all
um and yeah it is certainly weird to see
anime become way more [ __ ] popular
nowadays even though none of us watch it
anymore
right joey oh yeah
the more the more popular anime has
become the less i've watched
like symbiotic do you watch as much
anime now cali i mean to be honest i
feel like all the anime i'm really
interested in is older stuff that i get
recommended for example kaiji and baki
i've been really into
fun
pleasure oh yeah are you caught up on
the anime no i've been sl that is the
only one that i have been slowly
watching because i don't want it to end
so i've been like
day by day watching an episode nice it's
so good i love that i still need to
watch the anime what part are you on if
i'm allowed to ask um let's see what
part did we stop off at um let me think
because i've been watching with a friend
who is also a big fan
and we've been watching like at the same
time like overseas completely separated
from each other um let me see which part
were we at what was the last thing that
happened yeah was the most iconic thing
that happened i didn't mean every
episode
i think i think baki officially
challenged um his father i think it was
the last thing that happened that i saw
i'm like trying to happen like 10 times
yeah
maybe
do you realize how little that narrows
it down
in the new season
i have yeah i have two oh okay you're
pretty far then yeah when i started
watching uh bucky i actually didn't um i
challenged myself and i didn't watch it
with english subtitles i watched it
completely japanese with japanese only
subtitles and i did not figure out that
baki's dad was who he is until i put on
the subtitles i felt so ashamed i was
like wow so many three years self-study
japanese and i can't even figure that
out
i i feel you i feel you
because sometimes like
have you has like
do you watch all anime unsubbed now then
or do you watch like some sub some
unsubbed ah you know it depends usually
what i'll do is if it's one that i've
seen before i'll watch it without
subtitles yeah um but i mean i do watch
it with subtitles but they're japanese
subtitles so i at least get the kanji to
like help me out if i can't really hear
how sometimes
yeah do if if there's like something you
don't understand you like rewind as well
and like just to see if you sound like a
nightmare it is a nightmare i mean
that's how you learn that's how you like
you're not watching you're not watching
it in the same way that you're watching
to enjoy anymore it is a learning
experience study material yeah it is
study material i mean in terms of
studying material i can think of worse
study material than anime yeah but for
sure it's it's the sacrifice you have to
make i guess
that's why you got to like use like as
soon as you've already seen and like are
familiar with right it's not really bad
because like when i was with i was
hanging out with some japanese friends
and everyone was watching kaiji and i
watched it too and of course there were
no english subtitles so i was watching
and i recall going home and going on
wikipedia and looking up what happened
there are some shows that are easier to
follow than others i can barely follow
like the rules of what have is happening
in kaiji in english yeah let alone in
another language
yeah i mean there's peppa pig plot lines
man those things are [ __ ] complex man
you know very complex honestly you laugh
but yeah i i took i took ladybeard's
advice and i started watching peppa pig
in japanese yeah and i could tell my
japanese was improving by how much of
peppa pig i could understand
and then like it got to a point where i
could understand eighty percent eighty
to nine percent of peppa pig and i was
like that was the first time i felt holy
[ __ ] i'm actually making [ __ ]
progress like thanos with his hand
this is power
oh [ __ ] peppa pig's a good shot
and then i graduated to normal anime
after that and uh
even then there are some anime you have
to be very selective in the anime you
watch if you want to treat anime as a
study material because some things are
just like
just like so far beyond your level becky
seems like a hard one to choose yeah
because i feel like baki would be pretty
hard because there's so much explanation
of like what is happening on screen and
like the backstory and stuff oh trust me
i read the manga and i sometimes have to
like double take me like what the [ __ ]
it's like it's like sometimes baki is
like a visual storytelling medium and
then sometimes it's really not you know
sometimes it's a novel yeah exactly
i remember where i was we just left the
prison p please don't spoil it for me
please chat please i beg of you don't
spoil it for me we also do fake speech
[Laughter]
static chats
because we do we do fake spoilers in my
chat uh so people you can't trust anyone
what anyone's saying so i say guys throw
out some fake spoilers so people who are
putting out real spoilers could be lying
we don't know that's how i protect
myself don't worry bucky's one of those
shows where you could give out a real
spoil and you'll be like i guess that's
what happens
we gave out a bunch last episode
actually yeah
we literally just talked about bucky so
it's so good wasn't planned at all that
we'd mentioned bucky again
well thank you very much for building on
what we said before please go and watch
that yeah watch back please
it is now
approved so uh green reaper
i know i know you guys are here too
because i know i have a lot of i have a
lot of fans of me who literally come to
my stream and say i came here from trash
taste
a lot of deadbeats whose names i see
over and over and over again who are
always there i'm just i'm really
thankful to you guys thank you so much
for bringing me so many cool dead beats
oh you came on man yeah yeah you did the
work yeah
i just sat here and asked you questions
how have uh how has it been since uh
that episode and how has like life been
in japan over the last year oh man you
know interestingly enough and i i hate
to say it it's been a little sad only
because i really haven't gotten out of
the house much and like i can't i can't
figure out if it's because of the
situation the world is in or because now
i'm officially a workaholic so
i can't figure it out i thought i think
i think i know which is the answer to
that one um
if i had to say both just a distraction
uh yeah it's probably just like a
combination combination of both you know
definitely i'm also a workaholic so i
know it's the second one oh man i how
did i outed in front of everything
that's how it is
i'm married i i remember when connor
wasn't a workaholic and then he
discovered streaming and then that was
like the that was like the spare time
that he had is now like dedicated to
streaming it turns out when you don't
really enjoy what you're making it's
really easy to like not do it
but when you enjoy it it's like really
hard to not do it yeah right kind of
like
spinning bars bro imagine enjoying your
job yeah that's crazy man
i just thought a job was something you
don't enjoy but you do because you have
to do it because everyone does it that's
what my perception of jobs was when i
was growing up yeah well i worked at
mcdonald's for [ __ ] sake you think i
liked that i hated that i went away i
worked
[Music]
remind me
to remind me kelly do you know where i
worked before i think i do
remind me again i think i remember uh so
i worked at the bbc before
[ __ ] yeah that's right i was like abc
now
something like that that's that's the
american cup yeah that's right you must
have loved it cause you never shop about
it
you might i never shut up about it
because i [ __ ] hated it
i don't bring a mcdonald's every goddamn
week another people repost clips of you
from like years ago now talking about
how you used to work yeah before it was
a meme yeah before it wasn't me
except on god's business card it
actually says we used to work at the bbc
did it actually
i wouldn't put it past you to do that
ex bbc employee yeah
no it does it did for the record he's
just talking [ __ ] certified bbc employee
oh god
oh my god
so yeah like do you okay so like on the
vein of that do you probably see this as
a job or is it just something that you
enjoy so much that it doesn't feel like
a job and it's just so easy to do that's
a really good question i mean you know
all before this i was also working for
example service jobs there was never a
point in my life where i wasn't working
a job it was usually a job i didn't like
but i was saving up money to go to japan
you know um and even when i started
doing scythe swinging lessons that was
also something that i had a hard time
with every day waking up and feeling
like going to the same thing it like
wasn't satisfying to me i think that
there are plenty of people that can work
uh desk jobs and office jobs that love
it and have a great time or even if they
don't love it they're fine enough with
it to go home and just have a drink
under the impression that people just
went to work and then they did it just
so that they could like play games in
the evening that's what i thought jobs
were when i was growing up i mean i
think some people i think i think there
is jobs for most people yeah
that's why then when i when i was like
you know when i was doing youtube and
that was sometime i wasn't enjoying it
there was some parts i didn't enjoy i
was like oh this is normal it's a normal
job but now i really like it i'm
addicted yeah
for me it like comes in waves right it
depends on whether you're working
whether you enjoy what you're working on
or not sometimes if it's if you're
really passionate about it you know it's
just easy to do and uh when you're not
enjoying it then it's it is a grind
that's the sacrifice that we make for
being in very lucky positions you know
super lucky yeah but i will say it's
okay to not have a passion i just want
to put that out there
fine to not have one i think it's
perfectly fine to just do do your job
that you hopefully don't hate if you
hate i think if you hate it i think you
should stop it um and find a job that
you don't hate at the very least and
then go home and just do your hobby do
what makes you happy i think that's
great um but if you do have a passion
then i think it's it's nice to at least
give it a try to try to get it and if it
doesn't work out it doesn't work out
unfortunately as well most of the time
hobbies or passions aren't monetizable
passions and then but when you do start
to monetize it it stops becoming your
whole yeah yeah
like it's it's you know yeah i mean i
think it's obviously you're surrounded
in media especially by people who are
passionate about something because yeah
right you don't get there by not being
passionate so i definitely agree that it
doesn't give you this false sense of
everyone has to have a passion right
right and also it's cool i feel like i
see a lot of interviews that say things
like from people for example like us
who have been very successful at what we
do i see a lot of people say over and
over again just go for your dream you
can do it if you really believe and work
super hard i know that i've said
something like that in the past but i
want to very quickly correct myself
two things you gotta realize that you're
taking a risk you're making a gamble
because you need two things you need to
work hard and you need to be extremely
lucky and um you need to have both of
them you can't you can't just have one
you got to have both but the problem is
if you don't work extremely hard then
there's no chance there's no chance yeah
and it's it's it's it's scary to take
that chance in your life sometimes
because some people just don't have a
safety net and so like they go they they
[ __ ] yolo everything into this
passion and i'm just like i couldn't
[ __ ] do that yeah like like i respect
anyone who has who has the guts to do
that like for me like i had to save up
for like a year's worth of wages that i
would could live comfortably on yeah
before i was even comfortable quitting
to try and do youtube it could have been
three more videos yeah i know right
we never know
the three lost videos that god could
have made in that year i'm so sorry but
i i think that even the fact that you
had the balls to do that is quite
admirable because i'm sure there's a lot
of people who want to like you know get
into either what we do or some kind of
creative field that you know maybe might
have a year five years ten years worth
of savings and they could just never
take that first step forward yeah you
know so i think just doing that like you
know for me it's like i was still at
school when i started this whole thing
so you know i had that safety net well
if it doesn't work out i'll just get my
degree get a [ __ ] job it's also
difficult because i feel like when
you're talking to other people who are
successful
in that particular field you almost get
this like not not survivor bias but like
everyone's done it yeah so how do you
get an actual view of the whole
uh
the whole picture of the whole playing
field if your only perspective is from
talking to people who have made it
mm-hmm you know sometimes i think like
huh but then how how can you
you can't go to someone like hey you've
been trying for 15 years and you just
failed hey can you
talk to you for a moment can you figure
out what's going on like you can't you
know yeah remember that traumatic time
where you try to make it and you didn't
tell me about that you know like there's
you know it's not always like that where
people just do it forever like people
give up for many reasons yeah just stop
they don't necessarily give up but you
know there's a lot of like a lot of
factors come into play but also i do
think that sometimes i'm like huh maybe
i'm just talking to other people who
have just made it too much and i feel
like i can't actually get a good
perspective
yeah i mean i get that and i think that
we've just talked to enough people where
you see certain patterns like everyone
everyone like everyone doesn't everyone
has a different path no not everyone has
exactly the same path but you've noticed
certain patterns that keep cropping up
and you're like i kind of did that as
well and i'm just like you know you it
because because i thought that you know
i thought at the beginning there is
nothing you can do to like guarantee
success and there is nothing you can do
to guarantee success in our fields but
there are certainly things you can do to
increase your chances yeah right right
and and i feel like that just comes with
knowledge right that just comes with
just
the trial and error and just like what
kelly's experience where you start off
you're new you don't know what you're
doing and then eventually you do it
enough and then you're able to get the
opportunity to see what works and what
doesn't and obviously we've all have
been very lucky as you say uh as kelly
has said you need luck to succeed in
this field oh yeah yeah but there are
there are other things you can do that
can increase your chances of success as
well so there's no guarantees but there
is ways i think that you can increase
your chances what do you think you would
be doing now if you weren't a reaper
man you know
to be honest with you though i
genuinely answering a hundred percent
honest i'd still be trying
yeah i'd still be trying to make it with
music yeah yeah yeah yeah
i would not i just don't think i would
have given up because i don't know what
else to do see that's the other thing
guys if you you got to recognize
it's a gamble so you better like it you
better really really love it so that
even if you don't quote unquote pop off
or succeed you love like every second of
doing it i think is the most important
you know like back when i first came on
the podcast um i feel like i didn't
fully grasp it yet i was so kind of like
whoa i'm suddenly doing really well way
better than i've ever been in my life
this is because i worked hard i i
remember you coming on and you were so
like bright-eyed and you're just like so
optimistic
i mean that's why i had to like step
back for a minute though and correct
myself and say i was a little conceited
back then wasn't fully aware of what i
was doing but of course once you change
your stance on something on the internet
you're a hypocrite so that's just that's
just kind of how it goes
yeah
when did like when did like start to hit
you of like oh this is what the life is
like oh um let me see that is that's
another really good question you guys
got some some bangers today i'm sorry
no it's like interrogating
i'm just i'm just genuinely curious
here's the grind and the gears are
grinding um let me see it must have been
at the a million
subscriber endurance stream i think that
was when it really hit me things are
going to be extra different from now on
wow that was when we were really popping
off though like everyone was exploding
every single day with with new subs and
new members and and that was like the
prime you know and that was when it
really hit me like oh wow this is the
craziest thing i've ever done in my
existence and i'm extremely lucky yeah
wow and that was kind of when i changed
my stance on oh you just need to work
hard to get far in life
i realize now that's a little conceited
to say that it's not true it's not real
life
do you feel that uh
mentioning that you said that there was
like a big pop off an explosion do you
feel like it the scene has changed a bit
of the the way the viewers interact
changed over the year because i feel
like
the peak of it is kind of or like the
hype peak like the newness of it it's
kind of died down a little bit yeah yeah
i think yeah it's okay to admit that
it's it's kind of died down a lot
actually yeah um the market is really
saturated right now
yeah you don't say
you don't say first time
um
that is the that is the plain truth of
it all um there are a lot of people
interested in v tubing now it has gotten
really big a lot of people have come in
and also a lot of people have left a lot
of people have tried it out for several
months and realized it's not for them uh
all you know all the power to them good
for them but that's just kind of like
how it's gone you know um
you know that's how it goes with
anything you realize you're into
something you stick with it you realize
it's not your thing you drop out and
that's cool um but that's why there's
been a bit of like a a wave i think and
um
you know everyone i think a lot of
people have you know seen
youtubers they kind of know what they
are especially in like the anime sphere
i guess um
you know and i feel like um that's just
how things go sometimes you know
the longevity of something i hope that
people continue doing this yeah i hope
this keeps being something fun that
everyone can enjoy
i i i think v tubers are going to be
around for like the future because i
feel like yeah we've had our popularity
peak especially in the english uh
community and now it is much more
saturated and it i but i don't think
it's like died down i think it's more
like it's just leveled off right it's
flat it's plateaued that was the word
you know people are coming up with new
ideas every day an amazing new
technology some of these you know
individuals with 3d that they're doing
is like
mind-blowing you know and i think it's
going to keep you know evolving in its
own way and i'm really excited to see do
you ever feel like the pressure to have
to keep up to like you know keep
relevant as you know the youtube the the
word every youtuber [ __ ] loves
staying relevant
oh man i mean i think that's a worry for
everyone and if they say it isn't then
they're lying straight to your face at
least it's a teeny tiny bit yeah just a
little bit especially when it's your job
you know you you do worry about things
like that but i feel like my interest in
numbers drastically waned after like i
feel like um you know a lot of the core
fan base came in and we still get new
deadbeats all the time always very
welcome and opening to them but um it's
like i stopped caring as much about the
number situation when i started to
genuinely enjoy streaming and making
music um you know
as as me yeah right right
is it ever like a
frustrating when because you know we're
we're kind of in the same thing but
we're all like our own unique kind of
channel and whatnot is it ever like a a
frustrating thing that you know because
you obviously all the v tubers come in
as one package it's like this is the
generation how do you make sure that
there's not this kind of weird sense of
competition amongst fellow youtubers
because you're all kind of the same
thing right and you're not i mean you're
not the same but you're you're the same
target audience right yeah joey talks
about manga not anime and i i might go
and do something silly right or against
all my fate you know it's totally
different audience even though we are
kind of in the same market right yeah
yeah with v tubing i always wonder how
how do you like stop that from happening
like a competition like that uh you know
it's hard for me to speak on behalf of
the entire youtuber
yeah yeah as much as i support and love
like the work of what indies are doing i
don't have enough energy in my life to
go socialize with many outside of hulu
which i think is a shame and i wish i
could but it's just it's kind of
difficult to do so i can really only
speak about what i've seen within holo
but um
i just feel like somehow there was there
was some kind of magic involved in the
in the selection process where they just
they chose people
that we just we just don't really
get extra jealous of each other i mean
it's good at least this is me saying
from my perspective i don't know what's
going through the other side
i i can't speak on their behalf but i
can say from me um genuinely the people
that they chose i look at them and i
just want to see them succeed
i feel like part of me is is questioning
like well shouldn't you be wanting to be
better than x and so and so but i can't
i just can't parse that feeling i just
don't feel it that is the truth i mean
of course there's me wanting to be my
best but i guess here's a good example i
can give you from my past
i had my first my first really really
close friend ever was a friend that i
met in middle school who was the new kid
she moved to my city i had no friends in
that school um it was not great but this
new kid came and she was drawing she had
a how to draw manga book
hell yeah
and
i had been trying to figure out like
what is that art style called because i
didn't know where to search for it i was
young i had no idea and so she explained
it to me she opened up the whole world
to me and she let me borrow it and that
was when i started drawing and i came to
school the next day and people were like
wow you can draw really well you both
are really good some people were saying
callie you're actually
you you really you're you're maybe a
little better and i was like no that's
not true but that was like that was the
feeling that i got of i can do something
i i can do something and be good at it
and people are you know looking at what
i'm doing and then of course my friend
was also like
oh hell yeah let's let's learn together
and we became friendly rivals in that
like we were always kind of working
alongside each other drawing and like
you know maybe you show your friend a
picture you drew hey this is my original
character oh cool here's mine and like
you're still friends but like there's
this feeling of i gotta keep up with
this person you know and as i started
being involved in more art communities
as i as i grew older and you know met
friends on the internet etc we all were
still cool and friends with each other
but seeing others hard work made us want
to keep up
that kind of thing so and so drew this
well i want to i want to try doing that
let me see how how i can do you know so
it's not like an outright feeling of
jealousy but it's a feeling of wanting
to like make yourself better to keep up
i guess and it's like friendly
competition you know just
yeah this one's very healthy yeah that's
how it was for me personally
so no bad feelings that's right that was
a very good answer dude
that's the most wholesome
yeah yeah yeah i was like you know
waiting for the blood to be spilled
and then i stabbed her with the pen
in a close group of friends that kind of
like healthy competition can form i
think yeah you know instead of like a
wide group of people competing together
like a death game you know for example
death games on the mind sorry guys
but if it's like a small group of
friends it's really easy to foster like
a a healthy competition yeah i think
it's that like whole mentality that a
lot of people still
you know struggle to understand of like
if one person succeeds then you know the
rest can also come up yeah kind of
mentality and i feel that like at least
on like youtube and stuff like that and
probably you know in the youtuber
community as well where it's like if one
v tuber succeeds then everyone in that
same genre can also kind of rise up
together as a community and i feel
though as especially like a lot of the
smaller creators still don't quite
understand that yet i think in my eyes
like where it's like i know i need to be
better than this person well the the
normally the biggest channel in any
genre is an indication of
you know the size you can get the cap
off yeah it's normally a good way so you
know if someone at the top is blowing up
that's normally a good thing yeah yeah
yeah there's like more audience to
trickle down like i wouldn't have come
back to youtube if i didn't see joey
blowing up because i thought i thought
when i quit youtube i'd like reach the
ceiling my crown back
i was the guinea pig
it's like wow he's made a fart yeah
because i was just like i thought that i
had reached the ceiling of anime content
on youtube and at the time i had because
anime just wasn't as popular so i'm just
then i was like out of the way
i completed youtube
i came back for youtube too
the long-awaited sequel you were saying
kelly sorry awesome no you're good
you're good i was thinking like
personally i think the most healthy way
to like compete in general though isn't
to think about who you're gonna go past
but beating the you of yesterday so
inspirational hashtag wow yeah just
inspirational things hashtag motivated
sounds like a scene out of bucky
you're only as good as how many times
you've had sex
that's backy that's right but i mean if
you think about it though it really
there is some truth to it as long as you
are doing better than your past self as
long as i'm doing better than past me i
feel good yeah yeah yeah i mean it's
very easy to compare yourself to others
and then hold yourself to an absolute
standard you all want to be the gig of
chad but we can't yeah would you have
like any advice to up and coming for
youtubers nowadays now they've had like
a year of a year of experience right
you're the senpai now yeah you are the
senpai now i am um let's see maybe just
i'll pass along some advice that my
senpai had given to me never stop doing
new things
keep
keep trying new stuff
and that's that's the only way to be i
think
is to keep pushing the boundaries and
see what kind of wonderful stuff can can
come from this i think that's my advice
to you guys just passing on what i've
been doing oh yeah i mean i'd say that's
good advice for like any content
creators youtuber or not do you feel
sometimes that you would have an easier
time being like say an indiv individual
without having to like worry about
management and things like that oh
that's right well you know the way that
i kind of view it is yeah there are
restrictions and for the most part i get
why they're in place um right here right
now with me as i am um i'm happy to kind
of like
work around things for example there are
games that i can't always stream and
that's i can't do it at all actually and
that's fine a lot of them are ones that
i like a lot um but at the end of the
day
like i said been trying to be more
positive recently so the way that i
think about it is you know what out of
this list i will choose the ones that i
like and i will have fun with them and
um i think that's the best way to go
about it because you know life is uh
life is long
for the most part for the most part
and um
yeah
because of me uh it's not as long as it
could be but um
but however however
um you do a lot of things uh in in your
life and your existence you know and um
what one life ends one begins etc you
know that's how it was for me a long
time ago um so you never know what the
future will hold but right now with me
as i am uh just the mori in front of you
um
i can find workarounds and ways to still
have fun uh with the restrictions that
are in place and i think that that's
that's kind of the attitude to have if
you're gonna go into this and um
and uh and join a big company like like
whole life yeah you know you just gotta
you gotta kind of work with it get over
it you know was it something that you
were expecting the restrictions or was
kind of a shock
you know i think in the beginning i
thought that it would be a bit different
however i don't think like i mentioned
before none of us knew how big this was
going to be yeah yeah you know and when
that happens things kind of things kind
of change a bit
right when there's more money involved
more people get involved imagine
yeah when stuff blows up everyone wants
to take credit for it yeah
we live in a society
we
we're trying to keep this politics free
yeah thank you very much for scientists
yes
stay positive you know um what are some
of like the top ideas that you would
want to do if you like you had no
restrictions at all oh man it's mostly
games to be honest that i think about
collabs that i'd want to do with people
that just can't realistically happen you
know and um
and uh it's like there's there's not
just like protest from from my side
either from management but also from
from people who watch me and like i pay
attention to that kind of stuff i don't
let it completely influence me but like
i i do look at it um and try to you know
factor in as much as i can this is why i
have like no energy because there's so
much going on in my brain
to what games the chat wants you to play
i do but that's because like i genuinely
want like everyone to have a good time
and if i see the same thing happen over
and over again you know it gets it gets
in my mind but again it goes back to the
point where i said you can't every
single nice thing that said to you
that's a critique is not necessarily
going to help you will be helpful to you
so i just try to keep that in mind um
and stay open-minded the whole time um
but it's mostly just games and collabs
that i wish i could do that i kind of
realistically can't but it doesn't mean
that they'll never ever happen ever in
the history of ever it's just it's just
not like this yeah and i think that's
fine personally thank you for letting
cali come back on trash taste thank you
very much
and um i certainly am happy to be a
guest here yeah yeah thank you speaking
of future though like what's what's in
the future of cali
recently um you know there's a lot
there's a lot of ideas that i have
especially in terms of original song a
month that's still a thing that's
happening um i've got a big big collab
song coming out um with a fellow member
of en i think i've talked about this i
don't know how much of this will be
teased by the time that this comes out
but i hope you guys are looking forward
to it it is huge and we're working with
a huge producer like
like the likes of which i never thought
i'd be able to work with somebody
could you imagine the guy who wrote the
pokemon rap
i hope that you guys will enjoy it we've
been working really hard on it and um
yeah in general um i'm just trying to
prepare for another big release someday
and um
you know also in my in my crystal ball
we've got a possibility of um i'd really
like to do a world tour someday oh you
know that'll be that would be hype yeah
that would be hot i mean definitely
definitely at some point while i'm doing
this um
hopefully we will get a world tour
fingers crossed the world needs to open
up first before we have a world tour
well i say the world the world can't
heal until cali goes to every country
that's not possible the grim reaper has
to heal you yeah the healing has not
been done yet
it hasn't happened
to me aside from that though in the more
immediate future we have anime nyc
happening on november 20th november 20th
that's right we have a booth there
chad's like yeah yeah
that's it um we have a booth happening
um
it's nice to see that's a white board
being used for something other than like
saying incest
nyc we have a booth a holo booth but at
that same at that same place we have a
collab popping off i'm sure you guys
have seen by now uh with omocat um who
is he's designing clothes for all of us
in holo en uh myth right now and so that
is extremely exciting um because i've
been a big fan of cat for years and
years and years it's like a dream collab
oh geez yeah oh yeah yeah really amazing
amazing work and um also the creator of
omori i played that game on stream uh it
was a long stream
okay my favorite endurance streams of
all time so yeah i'm just really glad
that you know we got to we got to work
with all of them and uh yeah it's just
really cool i'm excited for you guys to
see the clothes they're awesome please
buy them please wear them uh and go
check out the booth yeah sounds like
you've got a lot of exciting things
coming up yeah there's a lot going on
stacked schedule
yeah right
even now there's still a lot of fun
stuff going on which is a relief that
after a year it's not like things are
slowing down or anything now we've still
got a lot going on and you guys haven't
seen everything that that myth or even
ian has cooked up just yet so stay tuned
i have a feeling you'll you'll continue
to be very busy yeah yeah it just seems
like it's speeding up yeah i was just
like maybe you'll find some free time
coming up oh the world's opening back oh
[ __ ] me man
it's like where do i find time well
sleep's only like six hours can i work
while i sleep
i'm gonna figure that out
that's why you were talking in your
sleep before you were
planning your next moves
why am i screaming in my sleep then
what's going on
yeah but i guess before we end things
off i do have a question for you yeah
you did give me a [ __ ] about pizza crust
last time you did so i gotta ask uh-huh
um
boneless chicken or in-bone chicken
boneless
i know what i'm talking about i'm done
guys thank you for coming to this
episode of trash this it's just the most
awesome i i would shake your hand but
we're on a different virtual plane
exactly i am in another dimension so
it's kind of rough but
congratulations virtual high five for
that one yeah gone is now the fourth
member of trash taste callie is now the
third member of the church
i'm gonna ask this every time a guest
comes on i'm going to find one [ __ ]
person who is on my side tell me why
boneless is better than that yeah why
why do you like the wait oh boneless
white's better than boning because the
bone's annoying exactly i mean i don't
want to eat around them it's worth the
taste okay it's worth the taste and
you're starting to see all the little
veins and like dark spots pop out it
just it's nasty i don't want to eat the
chicken anymore i think you should stop
asking that question unless you want to
get owned every episode i'm no i'm i'm
going to find a fellow brother or sister
so someone is going to come here and
back me up okay
one day one day you know who you are
you're out there right now i'm waiting i
am waiting for that time pov you're
gonna go to him he needs this
he needs this my god
i'm no longer a youtuber fan now
wait a minute
friendship would be cheaper
bone chicken is my best friend
oh my god don't eat your savage chicken
i mean i can eat bone-ins no i can't i
can't i just don't want to i prefer
boneless because i'm not an animal i
mean you can't eat bone and it's not
that much of an effort i can do it if i
have to i can't yeah i don't like it if
i got like 50 wet wipes on hand yeah we
can talk about doing it you know but i
don't want to
let's let's not start this
well thank you thanks for joining us at
another hour of the podcast of course
i'm always happy to come hang out with
you guys and uh it's been a blast thank
you very much for coming back on of
course any time of course we shouldn't
tell you this but uh link in the
description below to go check out cali
and all of our stuff you guys already
know yeah yeah yeah you'd like to know
are we premiering this episode again are
we doing it we're getting the super
chats already
[Applause]
my least favorite color is red so i
don't
i don't want to see it at all don't get
me wrong i do appreciate it but it does
there is a common theme even when i'm in
other streams the more that they say no
don't um the more that people get real
rambunctious and see it as a challenge
yes please i hate it my god oh my god
is that a
life hack i just heard right there
i can't stand colors just say no
just say no i hate money but if you like
support the show then make sure to go
don't donate don't donate to our patreon
don't don't go to a patreon look at
these guys look at look at these patrons
you don't want to be one of these people
okay
okay especially this guy don't be that
guy he's a loyal supporter but that you
know i mean
he doesn't throw a super chat
can i see his name right here in the
super chat no i'm sorry we're terrible
people i'm sorry we are terrible we
don't deserve a show
but if you would like to support the
show make sure to go to our patreon
patreon.com also follow us on twitter
send us your memes on the subreddit and
if you hate our face listen to us on
spotify and yeah thanks for coming on
kelly of course anytime thank you for
having me it's been great just seeing
you like grow in last year yeah it's
like been awesome seeing you just like
[ __ ] become really confident as a
streamer and just a content creator in
general and now i feel like i remember
the first like you first saw me you
coming on it did feel like yeah you did
were very bright-eyed you were very
optimistic and now i feel like we have a
lot more in common
you stopped giving a [ __ ] about what
people thought and just like enjoy doing
your own thing
it's a good sign so it's like a rite of
passage as a content creator
so join us yeah you've made it join us
well the same could be said for you guys
you guys have definitely popped off as
well this new place is amazing oh yeah
thank you for inviting me to it i'm glad
you didn't have to go over the trip
hazard this time all right we got to see
we got you actually got to sit in the
guest seat this time yeah exactly not
like this corner which is evolving yeah
yeah exactly we've also evolved for the
time but yeah that's been this episode
of trash taste i hope you enjoyed the
episode see you guys next week i guess
we say we say peace right yeah we gotta
say peace is super loud all right ready
three two one
[Music]
you